[Musique]
voir
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
surprise dans la république
chez emmanuel macron monsieur le
président c'est un char gérard larcher
monsieur le précédent président de f
monsieur le président je vous demande
d'accueillir mes chers collègues avec
l'enthousiasmé qu'il convient anne
hidalgo maire de paris qui nous fait
l'honneur de nous accueillir ici
monsieur le président de la république
cheikh emmanuel macron mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la mfr david lisnard
monsieur le vice président de la mef
cher andré laignel mesdames et messieurs
les ministres les parlementaires les
maires élus monsieur le président du
sénat est très cher françois baroin mais
surtout chers collègues et très chers
amis à l'issue de ces trois jours de
congrès je veux vous dire mon immense
bonheur mon immense plaisir que nous
ayons pu nous retrouver vraiment dans
ces lieux familiers tous ensemble qu'est
ce que ça fait du bien de se retrouver
le congrès de la mlf chaque année
marquent en effet les retrouvailles
d'une famille une famille à laquelle je
suis très fier d'appartenir une famille
que j'aime une famille avec ses
différences ses désaccords mais je suis
très heureuse de la voir réunis le
congrès qui s'achève
était un peu particulier il est resté
fidèle à cet esprit qui est le nôtre la
mmf et le lieu du débat ouvert
entre égaux entre maire de la plus
grande ville à la plus petite commune on
se parle on échange sur nos pratiques
on met sur la table nos ambitions nos
difficultés et le débat est toujours
fructueux car il se fait dans la
confiance mutuelle un respect issus de
notre engagement pour les françaises et
les français
cet esprit de la nef a été incarné
pendant sept ans par françois baroin
cher françois il ne m'appartient pas
[Applaudissements]
il ne m'appartient pas cher françois
debré tétons bilan mais quelques
souvenirs diront mieux que tous les
hommages le lien que nous avons
construit durant ces sept années un lien
de confiance et d'amitié mais aussi un
lien politique fondée sur une certaine
idée du rôle de la commune est de la
responsabilité des maires peut-être même
une certaine idée de la france
je me souviens bien sûr de la
marseillaise entonnée à l'unisson par
l'assemblée générale de la mf en
novembre 2015 au lendemain des terribles
attentats je me souviens aussi de jean
michel mathieu maire de signes tué en
voulant empêcher un fourgon de déversé
illégalement des crabes à et je me
souviens de l'hommage que nous lui avons
rendu ensemble je me souviens de votre
élan de solidarité
face à notre dame en feu mais aussi face
aux ouragans et irma et maria je me
souviens bien sûr aussi de notre
entraide face à la pandémie de notre
volonté de partager les solutions les
doutes les questions je me souviens
aussi de toutes ces réformes
territoriales qui se sont succédé à un
rythme effréné où nous avons porté
ensemble la voie des mers dans tous ces
événements heureux ou malheureux
nous avons été unis mais nous avons
aussi été conquérant
pragmatique réaliste car oui la mmf a
été engagée même si elle n'est jamais
partisane cher françois je veux te dire
mon immense reconnaissance car tu as été
le visage de notre association et au
delà l'une des voix les plus respectés
de france de la france des territoires
les maires de l'hexagone et des
outre-mer se savait fièrement représenté
à travers toi
monsieur le président cher david je sais
que tu souhaites aujourd'hui au site
inscrire dans cette même démarche que tu
sera attentif à perpétuer ce qui fait
notre force à savoir cette qualité
d'écouté des changes qui permet au delà
du débat de se tenir sans mettre en
cause notre unité comme moi tu es
attaché à maintenir notre formidable
diversité et à tes côtés
la sagesse l'expérience la pugnacité
d'andré laignel seront un appui précieux
merci à vous messieurs
monsieur le président de la république
vous pouvez faire confiance à cette
nouvelle équipe elle est pluraliste elle
est venue de tous les territoires pour
continuer de porter haut les couleurs
des mères ces piliers incontournables de
notre démocratie et de notre république
et l'accueil à paris du congrès c'est
bien plus qu'une tradition républicaine
c'est un engagement
le début de notre mandat a été très
particulier très difficile d'ailleurs
car dès le lendemain des élections mes
chers collègues le 15 mars 2020 nous
avons dû déjà élus ou réélus ou encore
entre deux tours nous concentrer
entièrement sur la crise sanitaire et
sociale et il fallait répondre présent
pour nos concitoyens pour leur apporter
des réponses alors que nous mêmes nous
n'en avions pas toujours n'attendons pas
la prochaine crise pour re découvrir une
nouvelle fois que la france tient quand
elle sait unir ses forces et s'appuyer
sur ces mères nous le savions avant les
manifestations des gilet jaune nous le
savions déjà aussi avant la crise
sanitaire nous le savions les maires
sont indispensables pour assurer la
cohésion du pays car face aux crises
l'état monsieur le président a fait son
possible mais les collectivités ont fait
tout le reste
l'unité l'unité elle se construit par la
confiance et nous le savons en
gouvernant hauteur de femmes et d'hommes
et c'est cela notre travail de maire
j'appelle de mes voeux un pacte de
confiance ce pacte dont nous avons tant
besoin entre l'état et les collectivités
un pacte de confiance qui bien sûr
s'inscrivent dans l'engagement dans le
fait qu'on ne change pas les règles
au milieu du jeu l'état doit faire des
communes des territoires où nous vivons
les acteurs centraux des politiques
publiques on parle souvent de ce dernier
kilomètre sans nous difficile d'avoir le
dernier kilomètre de la république la
décentralisation elle doit devenir une
règle de vie pour nous toutes et nous
tous c'est déjà le cas pour l'état aussi
et donc le moment est venu d'un état qui
accompagne qui veille aux grands
équilibres mais qui ça revient souvent
se dispense parfois de contrôle tatillon
de complexification ou de création de
normes de doctrine qu'il est souvent
difficile de comprendre
ce pacte de confiance enfin suppose
aussi un impact financier clair et
pérenne
par exemple les collectivités qui ont
tout assurer le service public pendant
le coc vide sans bien sûr bénéficier du
chômage partiel dont ont bénéficié à
juste titre les entreprises doivent tout
de même bénéficier de compensations de
l'état
vous le savez nous le savons seule une
loi de financement des collectivités
territoriales sera à même de porter ces
garanties pour l'autonomie financière
qui est nous le savons la condition de
la libre administration
ce principe garanti par la constitution
il nous faudra oser cette grande réforme
qui est je pense la condition d'une
confiance réciproque sans les moyens et
territoires les plus fragiles les
quartiers prioritaires les territoires
ruraux les outre-mer qui sont toutes
différentes seront condamnés à une forme
de décrochage et aucun républicain ne
peut accepter cette perspective monsieur
le président et mes chers collègues
cette confiance que nous appelons de nos
voeux pour nos habitants pour nos
territoires c'est aussi le moyen de se
hisser à la hauteur des défis du siècle
et tout le monde connaît cette maxime
célèbre mais terrible quand l'état
discute avec un maire il lui demande
quoi faire quand deux mers se voient ils
se demandent comment faire alors oui à
glasgow lors de la cop 26 j'ai pu à
nouveau vérifié la force de cette maxime
comment faire comment faire pour
résoudre ce défi majeur cette crise
climatique
et bien mes chers collègues nous le
voyons tous les jours tous les maires
sont engagés dans des actions concrètes
face à l'urgence écologique et au plus
près des citoyens mais surtout avec eux
on ne compte plus les villes les
villages les communes qui sont passés à
l'action pour notamment s'engager dans
la neutralité carbone après l'accord de
paris
l'adaptation la protection des
populations ne pourront se faire sans
les communes et les pouvoirs locaux de
même nous savons depuis 20 ans que nous
connaissons un une forme de séismes au
ralenti une tectonique des plaques qui
travaillent sourdement notre pays et qui
menacent notre cohésion ce mouvement en
terrible d'ailleurs prend parfois le
visage de la désindustrialisation
souvent aussi de cette fracture
territoriale qui est avant tout sociale
et qui prospère toujours sur des
fermetures de services publics d'école
d'hôpital sur la place de la sécurité
sur la place de la justice sans parler
bien sûr des déserts médicaux et nous le
savons les communes rurales constituent
bien souvent les premières victimes de
ce délaissement alors il faut renforcer
tous ses liens entre les territoires et
avec l'état sur des projets jeu j'en
veux pour preuve ce grand projet qui
nous fédère tous du chef de l'état à
toutes les communes de france c'est les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
paris 2024 que nous aurons en partage
nous travaillons entre tous ces
territoires le déficit démocratique
nous le savons aussi est très important
et l'échelon local est tout sauf un
échelon à politique c'est même le lieu
de l'engagement politique au sens noble
du terme de cet engagement réel que nous
voyons tous les jours parce que débattre
d'un rond-point d'une piste cyclable de
la gestion de l'eau de choix en matière
d'habitat de développement économique
c'est débattre de la vie que nous
voulons mais il faut redonner cette
envie de démocratie nous le savons dans
un contexte où les élections sont
marquées par des taux d'abstention
extrêmement important et il nous faut
donc là aussi travaillé à la reconnexion
de nos concitoyens avec les institutions
ce qui est un impératif démocratique
je veux enfin dire un mot de la parité
la présence des femmes en politique est
plus que jamais un enjeu majeur et la
loi jospin l'a fait progresser mais ce
chemin est loin d'être terminée et nous
n'avons pas encore transformé en
profondeur la politique française la
misogynie qui s'expriment sans limite
ces derniers temps sur nos antennes en
est un témoignage c'est pourquoi je
souscris pleinement cher david monsieur
le président aux propositions formulées
par la mf sur ce sujet essentiel et que
je veux saluer toutes mes collègues ici
présentes et qui savent de quoi je parle
[Applaudissements]
oui ce sera aussi un impératif
démocratique d'accélérer cette parité
réelle dans les mandats exécutifs locaux
et au delà bien sûr mes chers collègues
qui aurait imaginé qu'une crise
planétaire mettrait en évidence notre
rôle indispensable parce que dans la
proximité
j'espère que les mois à venir nous
aurons l'occasion de travailler ensemble
en harmonie pour servir et protéger nos
concitoyens
alors faisons confiance au maire ils et
elles portent les valeurs de la
république
la tension à nos concitoyens les
solutions aux crises et l'espoir d'un
pays rassemblés autour de son avenir et
de l'avenir de sa jeunesse je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame le maire de paris merci
sharan de cet accueil quel symbole ici
dans cette capitale dont nous sommes
tous quelque part non pas les
dépositaires mais les habitants de voir
perpétuer cette tradition de l'accueil
du congrès des maires par le maire de
paris par ma part madame la maire de
paris c'est un symbole elle parlait de
communes et de communes de paris dans
l'histoire c'est aussi un symbole fort
c'est celui qui nous rassemblent
aujourd'hui et pour évoquer la
résolution des communes je vais donner
la parole aux premiers vice présidents
n'ont pas éternel mais en tout cas
enthousiaste de l'association des maires
de france qui ne manque pas de
résolution puisqu'il l'est mais même au
pluriel andré laignel à vous la parole
monsieur le premier vice président
merci mon cher david monsieur le
président de la république monsieur le
président du sénat
madame messieurs les ministres mesdames
messieurs les parlementaires
mon cher françois
cheran gérante d'abord merci pour les
mots que tu as eu
à l'égard de l'équipe que nous formions
avec françois et à mon égard je suis tu
le sais particulièrement
tant que je connais la détermination ton
amour de la commune que tu viens de nous
rappeler et donc merci a toi
je voudrais remercier
les membres du bureau de l'association
des maires de france qui réunit pour la
première fois ce matin
mon à l'unanimité des suffrages exprimés
réélu au poste de premier vice président
délégué de l'association des maires de
france
c'est
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien entendu pour moi un gage de
reconnaissance de votre part
et le sentiment que le travail que nous
avons accompli
françois a dit dans son propos mardyck
j'étais son stagiaire
j'ai simplement répondu ça prouve que
j'ai encore des marges de progression
eh bien je me réjouis que le stagiaire
et était prolongé dans ses fonctions et
que nous puissions ensemble aux côtés de
david
continuer à oeuvrer un vrai pour chacune
de nos communes à un vrai à travers elle
pour l'avenir de notre pays
nous avons dans cette première réunion
du bureau de l'association des maires de
france ce matin que constater la belle
diversité des talents
mais aussi les caractères qui se révéler
et nous avons beaucoup travaillé
cette et complexes nous sortions d'une
campagne
et nous avons ensemble poussé le
dialogue jusqu'à la nécessité d'être
réunies mais c'est donc avec fierté
que je vais dans un instant vous
présenter la résolution de l'assemblée
générale du 63e congrès des maires de
france qui a été adoptée à l'unanimité
par le bureau de l'association
[Applaudissements]
ce sens ce troisième congrès des maires
nous a permis de nous retrouver enfin
après avoir été contraint d'annuler
l'édition de l'année précédente les
maires de france et leur équipe ont dans
cette période fait honneur à leur mandat
en étant toujours au plus près de nos
concitoyens lors de ces mois difficiles
et nous avons évidemment une pensée pour
tous ceux qui ont été touchés de près ou
de loin par la pandémie
ce congrès est aussi le premier depuis
les dernières élections municipales
c'est toujours un moment particulier
d'un nouveau collègue découvre le
congrès accueilli par les plus
expérimentés d'entre nous
c'est à la faveur de ses rencontres et
de ses échanges que se forge l'esprit
commun qui nous unit au delà de nos
diversités de nos communes et de la
différence de nos parcours c'est aussi
ça la force du congrès des maires et
plus largement de la mf mettront en
valeur ce qui nous unit et venons de le
prouver à la faveur de nos élections
internes
c'est la vie normale d'une association
que de renouveler ses instances
dirigeantes
mais ce n'est jamais banal quand ses
adhérents sont les 35000 maires et
présidents d'intercommunalités de france
nous avons connu ces derniers mois un
débat interne de qualité qui a confirmé
la vitalité démocratique de notre
association
malgré les turbulences
l'essentiel a été préservé
notre unité et notre indépendance
vis-à-vis de tout pouvoir en sortent
confortés
c'est donc au final notre force
collective qui a triomphé
notre congrès est aussi le dernier du
quinquennat
cette temporalité a fait de ces trois
jours un temps fort du débat sur l'état
de notre pays et le fonctionnement de
nos institutions
le maire
le président de la république sont les
deux figures les plus connues de nos
concitoyens et sur lesquelles repose
tant d'attentes et tant d'espoirs les
prochains mois seront décisifs pour
l'avenir de notre pays et nous avons
pour mission d'être à la hauteur de nos
responsabilités
en faisant entendre notre voix celle de
la première ligne démocratique celle du
socle républicain celle des maires de
france
nous sommes fiers de ce congrès le plus
important de france qui a su rassembler
tant de participants et ce dans le
strict respect des règles sanitaires
pour la sécurité de chacun
beaucoup d'ailleurs pu suivre pour la
première fois nos travaux grâce à notre
webtv en somme nous avons une nouvelle
fois c'est la preuve du rôle
irremplaçable de notre association est
de la place centrale qu'elle occupe pour
la vitalité du débat démocratique
si aux yeux de certains la mf se
montrent trop à dos il
sait qu'elle n'a toujours eu et n'aura à
l'avenir qu'une seule et même ambition
porter haut et fort quel que soit le
gouvernement en place la voix des 34
1970 meilleurs de france
[Applaudissements]
et cette voix à l'attentât d'hier cette
année encore nous avons tant à dire sur
la manière dont nous pouvons porter
durablement la relance économique
nous avons porte à dire sur les moyens
dont nous devrions disposer pour
affronter la crise sociale et
accompagner les plus fragiles qui se
retourneront vers nous pour leur venir
en aide nous avons porte à dire sur le
fonctionnement de l'école dans les temps
de crise nous avons tant à dire sur
l'amélioration de notre système de santé
qu'à montrer ses forces et plus encore
ces failles nous avons tant à dire sur
l'indispensable transition écologique
que nous devons tous préparés et qui
passera par des solutions concrètes et
de proximité dans nos communes
sur tous ces sujets comme sur beaucoup
d'autres nous avons moins besoin d'une
avalanche de normes
tatillonne que de dialogue de
négociation et de construction commune
notre pays a besoin d'un véritable
projet de démocratie rénové
depuis de trop nombreuses années les
lois concernant les collectivités dont
le projet de loi 3ds est la dernière
illustration
s'apparente plus à un catalogue de
petites mesures parfois bienvenue mais
manque singulièrement de souffle et ne
constitue en aucun cas une politique à
la hauteur des enjeux
notre congrès a souvent mis en lumière
ce manque d'ambition c'est
particulièrement le cas pour les mesures
de soutien aux collectivités pour
pallier les conséquences financières de
la crise sanitaire les recettes qui est
libre de services publics se sont
érodées alors que dans le même temps
nous avons dû supporter des dépenses
nouvelles
or le gouvernement n'a proposé que des
dispositifs sous dimensionné et arnys
tel le prétendu filet de sécurité dont
la faiblesse va entraver notre capacité
à investir et donc à réussir le plan de
relance
[Applaudissements]
la même logique a conduit à ne pas
entendre les maires sur la politique de
logement et engendrer la grave crise que
nous vivons actuellement tentons pointé
du doigt par l'état pour leur supposée
inaction tentes ont dénoncé pour leur
propension à générer de l'étalement
urbain les maires sont sous le feu d'un
jeune qui sont contradictoires et
infondées
[Applaudissements]
en matière de sécurité nous faisons face
à une pléthore d'annoncés de grand-messe
entre guillemets sans lendemain derrière
cette façade la réalité souvent celle
d'un transfert de compétences sans
moyens correspondants
la marée des inégalités ne cessent de
monter il faudra bien plus que quelques
digue construite à la va-vite pour
l'arrêter en tant que maire nous sommes
aux premières loges les territoires
d'outre-mer les territoires ruraux les
territoires de la politique de la ville
sont ceux qui concentrent encore et
toujours le plus de difficultés
or trop peu a été fait et le temps se
perd il faudrait bien plus qu'un plan de
relance pour résorber les difficultés
structurelles que subissent les
territoires ultramarins ce n'est pas
l'agenda rural dont la mise en oeuvre
actuelle reste trop limitée qui répondra
au malaise des habitants et des mères
qui tente de faire vivre les communes
rurales
mais ce ne sont certainement pas le
grand discours parfois caricaturaux qui
feront sortir nos banlieues de l'état de
relégation dans laquelle sont plongés là
encore les espoirs qui avaient été
suscitées ont été déçus et le sabordage
du rapport borloo justifie la
mobilisation de nos collègues maires de
quartiers prioritaires de la politique
de la ville nous faisons à cet égard
notre l'appel de grigny et son conseil
national des solutions
cette instruit de toutes ces occasions
manquées et ses espoirs déçus que nous
veillerons à la mise en oeuvre effective
des contrats de relance et de transition
écologique
la détermination des maires à développer
leur territoire prime toujours sur les
déceptions passées
nous vérifierons scrupuleusement que les
moyens promis dans le cadre des ccr t1
soit bien versé au bénéfice des projets
tels qu'ils ont été définies localement
un dernier exemple tout à fait
symbolique le recul du trait de côte
le dérèglement climatique entraînera
dans nos territoires avec l'érosion du
littoral la disparition de dizaines de
milliers de logements de routes
d'équipements publics face à cet enjeu
majeur pour des milliers de communes la
seule réponse de l'état d'étendre la
taxe gma pis alors qu'elle a déjà bien
du mal à financer ce qui est dans son
périmètre ce n'est évidemment pas à la
hauteur d'un enjeu qui doit relever de
la solidarité nationale
[Applaudissements]
si nous considérons que de nombreux
dispositifs aux objectifs louables
manque d'ambition c'est parce que notre
exigence à l'endroit du gouvernement
est le reflet de celle que nos citoyens
ont à notre égard
nous avons certes obtenu quelques succès
et la mfm mobilisé sur tous les dossiers
dans un esprit constructif de même nous
saluons les progrès que constitue la
création de l'agencé nationale de la
cohésion des territoires et les
programmes coeur de ville est petite
ville de demain
malgré ces avancées nous demeurerons
intransigeant face au mouvement de
recentralisation qui s'opèrent depuis
plusieurs années marquées par le retour
des tutelles
la décentralisation n'est pas à l'arrêt
elle recule
la première manifestation de cette
offensive contre les acquis de la
décentralisation
c'est bien évidemment le recul de
l'autonomie financière et fiscale des
collectivités locales
l'attak la plus visible
[Applaudissements]
l'attak la plus visible a été la
nationalisation
qui n'est pas une suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
d'autant qu'elle conduit aujourd'hui à
de puissants transferts financiers des
territoires ruraux vers les grandes
métropoles
[Applaudissements]
c'est ensuite ajouté la réduction
imposée de nos impôts économique qui se
traduit par la rupture entre une commune
et ses acteurs économiques du lien
fiscal qui permet tait d'établir des
engagements réciproques
l'ifer a aussi été ciblés si cette
réforme a fort heureusement pu être
évité grâce notamment à la mobilisation
de la mf cet acharnement à vouloir
supprimer toute possibilité de lever des
impôts locaux dynamique sonne comme une
menace pour l'avenir
cette mise à mal de l'autonomie
financière et fiscale nous met en
situation de grave dépendance nos
budgets ne se plie en réalité que des
budgets annexes de celui de l'état
[Applaudissements]
à cela
s'ajoutent les pseudos
contractualisation type contrat de
cahors léonard et tutélaire mais aussi
les appels à projets et autres fléchage
qui limite de plus en plus nos choix
d'investissement
lorsque l'état cadenassent les
collectivités limitent leurs compétences
réduit leur autonomie alors la
décentralisation est moribonde les élus
locaux sont réduits au rôle de simples
figurants
la décentralisation
n'est pas une réforme technique
c'est un projet politique une règle si
j'ai notion de la démocratie une
certaine vision de la société de l'
équilibre des pouvoirs et de la façon
dont se constituer vie une nation
nous avons la tristesse de constater les
attaques que cette idée que cette idée a
subi que penser et dire du recul si ce
n'est de l'exclusion de la place des
maires dans le processus de la décision
politique comment interpréter la volonté
de reporter grossièrement et donc
marginaliser les scrutins locaux
comment faire comprendre qu'il n'ya pas
de place dans notre pays pour le soupçon
de carence républicaine quand on parle
des 35000 mère qui tous les jours font
vivre la république et son principe de
laïcité plus que n'importe quelle autre
institution
sans évoquer les attaques dont ils ont
fait l'objet dans des campagnes de
communication honteuse qui ont blessé
les maires
la france a besoin du souffle puissant
d'une grande loi de liberté locale une
loi qui libère les initiatives qui
libère les énergies qui rétablit la
confiance entre 1 et à renforcer dans
ses missions prioritaires et des
collectivités responsables de tout ce
qui peut et doit être fait au plus près
et au service du citoyen
on ne réussira par la france sans les
maires
ce n'est pas hasard
eh oui
on ne réussira pas la france sans vous
sans nous sans les maires ce n'est pas
un hasard s'il mer reste la seule figure
plébiscité par les français
continuent à en faire exception à la
perte de confiance de nos concitoyens
dans les institutions trois forces trois
français sur quatre font confiance à
leur maire un chiffre en augmentation
ces dernières années qui est la marque
que nos combats pour la commune n'ont
pas été vains
parce qu'elle est d'abord un espace de
vie sociale de débats des changes de
proximité de fraternité la commune reste
le point d'ancrage majeur pour nos
concitoyens
dans un monde où les repères sont
bouleversés si malgré toutes les
difficultés nous choisissons d'être élu
local
ce n'est pas pour regarder le monde
change et pour voir défiler dans nos
permanences tous les espoirs et toutes
les misères humaines sans avoir de
réponse
c'est pour agir
ce que nous demandons
ce régime finalement un mot simple et
vous que l'état semble avoir rayé de son
dictionnaire
confiance
faites nous confiance
parce que la libre administration des
communes et créatrices de valeurs
d'efficacité
l'investissement dans l'avenir
d'engagement citoyen
est maintenant
un nouvel élan de liberté
le temps est venu de nous tourner vers
l'avenir avec détermination et ambition
la crise des derniers mois des dernières
années nous oblige à l'unisson avec nos
amis et partenaires de territoire unis
nous appelons de nos voeux une grande
loi sur les libertés locales qui ouvre
une étape nouvelle de la
décentralisation cette loi repose sur
des principes simples
donner sens à l'organisation
décentralisée de la république s'est
d'abord consacré la commune comme
cellule de base de la démocratie comme
clé de voûte de nos institutions
républicaines
la place de la commune doit être protégé
au sein de notre loi fondamentale en
inscrivant la clause de compétence
générale dans la constitution
[Applaudissements]
la grande loi de décentralisation que
nous appelons de nos voeux doit remettre
le maire au coeur des grandes décisions
d'aménagement de son territoire qu'il
s'agisse du logement où par exemple
d'implantation d'éoliennes
la compétence en matière de paix et lui
doit être réaffirmé comme une compétence
communale par définition est
intercommunale par exception
[Applaudissements]
le maire seul à la légitimité
démocratique pour engager l'avenir et la
transformation de son territoire
pour pouvoir pleinement agir nous
exigeons en outre un réel pouvoir
réglementaire l'état du droit le permet
il suffit simplement que l'exécutif lève
le stylo pour qu'ils puissent s'épanouir
cela allégera des textes souvent trop
bavard étouffant et permettra d'adapter
efficacement la règle aux réalités
locales
enfin
nous appelons à la fin des tutelles
juridique les lois de décentralisation
de 1982 ont ouvert la voie en supprimant
le contrôle a priori de nos décisions ce
fut à la fois un symbole fort et un
puissant catalyseur de l'innovation
locale il convient aujourd'hui d'aller
plus loin encore en supprimant le déféré
préfectoral
il s'agit pas de s'opposer aux préfets
qui sont souvent de précieux alliés mais
de faire advenir une relation basée sur
la confiance la relève et la
responsabilité les maires pourront
demander en amont la vie des préfectures
les préfets pourront toujours pour
tester la légalité mais nous éliminerons
définitivement ce qui s'apparente à une
présomption d'illégalité
[Applaudissements]
mettre fin aux tutelles c'est aussi est
toujours donnée aux élus locaux des
conditions dignes d'exercice de leurs
mandats
dignité dans le statut d'abord les veufs
et tous les jours confrontés à des
questions légitimes de ses adhérents sur
le sujet il nous faut aussi évoquer la
dangereuse épée de damoclès pénale qui
pèsent sur les élus locaux et notamment
l'application adhérentes des textes sur
le conflit d'intérêt et la prise
illégale d'intérêts
aujourd'hui la loi doit être réécrite
pourrait plus précises dans l'esprit de
ce que propose la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
la grande loi de décentralisation que
nous attendons devra garantir
l'autonomie financière et fiscale c'est
une question existentielle pour nous car
sans elles nous sommes condamnés à être
de simple sous traitant de l'état le
principe d'autonomie financière auquel
il conviendrait d'adjoint de l'autonomie
fiscale et dont c'est par la
constitution n'est plus qu'un bref
principes bafoués
l'autonomie fiscale bien sûr ne peut
s'entendre que dans le cadre d'une
réforme importante de la fiscalité
locale qui est aujourd'hui illisible
pour les citoyens injuste à bien des
égards est souvent inefficaces cette
réforme est complexe comme tous les
sujets difficiles il faut l'aborder avec
une boussole simple une fesci qualité
dédiés à chaque strate de collectivités
l'autonomie financière c'est aussi
abordé la question des dotations
rappelons avec force que la dgs n'est
pas un cadeau de l'état mais l'argent
que ce dernier doit aux collectivités
locales en compensation des charges
transférées et des exonérations fiscales
qu'il décide seul
[Applaudissements]
les dotations doivent être sanctuarisés
indexés mais également libres de toute
affectation nous ne pouvons que déplorer
que les dotations d'investissement des
notaires et des cils en premier lieu
soit de plus en plus encadré dans des
appels à projets qui créent une graves
inégalités entre les collectivités une
commune une intercommunalité c'est quels
sont les besoins de son territoire c'est
à elle de décider de ses investissements
et non à l'état central
de même
nous souhaitons une loi de finances
annuelles spécifique retraçant
l'ensemble des relations financières et
fiscales avec l'état c'est la condition
première d'une discussion sereine et
transparente sur les ressources de nos
collectivités
enfin nous devons donner corps aux
principes de subsidiarité
il faut toujours décider et agir au
niveau le plus proche possible celui du
citoyen il nous faut ouvrir le chantier
de nouveaux transferts de compétences
aux communes pour que la proximité du
service public devienne une règle d'or
bien sûr c'est le domaine de la santé
qui vient d'abord à l'esprit qu'il
s'agisse de la gouvernance des hôpitaux
de la vaccination ou de la lutte contre
les déserts médicaux les maires sont en
première ligne mais non par la
reconnaissance juridique de cette
compétence de fait le temps est venu de
tirer les leçons de la crise sanitaire
est d'inscrire dans la loi une
compétence claire du maire dans le
domaine de la santé
[Applaudissements]
nous plaidons également pour un nouveau
partage de compétences en matière de
culture et de sport qui sont des
politiques publiques porté et financé
quasi intégralement par les
collectivités en particulier les
communes
l'exemple récent de la métropole
marseillaise bien triste manque rappelé
que le principe de trois axes imiter est
aussi un principe d'efficacité
les intercommunalités dit xxl ne sont
pas la solution pour gérer les
compétences comme la propreté urbaine où
la voirie nous l'avons toujours pensé la
réalité l'a démontré la future loire
soit enfin réglé la question de la
compétence eau et assainissement
on dit que les faits sont têtus la
nature l'est aussi et la carte des
nappes phréatiques a le mauvais goût ne
doit pas s'adapter à la carte des
périmètres institutionnels des
intercommunalités
[Applaudissements]
par cette résolution
nous entendons tendre la main et des
parties un climat stérile de défiance à
notre égard
nous ne sommes certes pas d
interlocuteur commode
mais nous sommes des interlocuteurs
franc et sans la liberté de blâmer il
n'est point d'éloge flatteur
plus encore nous sommes des
interlocuteurs loyaux loyaux à nos
valeurs aux intérêts de nos communes qui
ne sont si l'on veut bien nous entendre
que les intérêts de notre pays
dialogues négociations confiance est-ce
trop demander et pourtant c'est ce que
nous n'avons pas pu avoir ces quatre
dernières années l'espérance la future
mandature qui s'ouvrir en 2022 le
permettra enfin car la gravité de la
situation le nécessite comme l'ont
démontré les crise que nous avons
traversée que nous vivons encore les
communes sont un atout majeur pour
construire l'avenir de la france et de
l'union européenne le reconnaître est il
si difficile pour l'état
sa culture l'empêchent style de
considérer à égalité les élus locaux et
leur légitimité
la france n'a rien à gagner à
l'affaiblissement démocratique au
sentiment d'abandon de larges pans de la
population à la dégradation des services
de proximité alors puisque pour certains
cela ne semble pas les deux soirs disons
le avec force la france a besoin de nos
villes et de nos villages de nous
outre-mer de nos campagnes et nos
quartiers de leurs élus et
fonctionnaires territoriaux nos
propositions nous les présenterons aux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
c'est un pacte républicain que nous
souhaitons acté pour que la démocratie
reprennent des couleurs que la justice
des territoires soit une grande cause de
la nation tout entière mais ignorées
serait un handicap pour le pays tout
entier ayons l'audace d'ouvrir de
nouveaux espaces de liberté
reconstruisons avec l'état la confiance
dont a besoin la nation pour ensemble
faire réussir la france c'est cette
ambition collective que nous proposons
vive la commune vive la république et
vive la france
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président de la république
je suis à emmanuel macron
monsieur le président du sénat mon cher
gérard larcher mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
madame la maire de paris sharan hidalgo
mesdames et messieurs les maires mes
chers collègues je m'adresse bien jouent
bien sûr avoue urbi et orbi mais aussi
derrière moi et j'espère vous ne
pardonnez pas de vous tourner le dos
mais n'y voyez là qu'une posture
physique mais non pas moral
c'est dans la commune que réside la
force des peuples libres
la liberté
les institutions communales
mettre la liberté à portée du peuple
les institutions communales sont à la
liberté
ce que sont à la science les écoles
ainsi s'exprime et alexis de tocqueville
l'une de nos plus belles plumes l'un
d'eux le plus grand penseur
décédé à cannes est d'ailleurs auquel la
ville de cannes rendra hommage dans
quelques mois
alors oui mes chers collègues dans
l'esprit de cette résolution
que nous voulons entendre avec
le talent la compétence et l'éloquence
d'andré laignel
c'est dans cet esprit de liberté de
responsabilité que je vous propose de
clore notre et de clôturer notre congrès
oui pour l'avenir de notre pays
je vous propose de parler de liberté et
de responsabilité
de liberté et de responsabilité locale
concrète
les communes sur le présent la
république monsieur le président c'est
là mais chers collègues
sont le socle de notre république
la belle et grande république française
elles forment la cellule de base
de son organisation
les communes et sa collègue viennent du
fond de notre histoire elles sont
enracinés elles sont la concrétisation
humaine de notre géographie
elles sont le creuset de notre culture
dont on sait qu'elles nous sauvera et de
nos racines communes de nos racines
communes individuelles et collectives
les communes samson à l'expression de
pierre manent disciple de raymond aron
des communautés d'expérience donc
des communautés de sentiment
d'appartenance
le sentiment d'appartenance précisément
à la communauté à la même communauté à
la communauté nationale est source de
performance publique
les communes de france
participe alors place singulière à la
cohésion de la nation
et chaque fois que celle ci est menacée
cette cohésion de la nation eh bien nous
les maires nous portons d'un seul élan
aux côtés de l'état pour contribuer à
l'unité du pays face aux risques nous
l'avons fait neil faisons nous le ferons
c'est dire monsieur le président de la
république combien votre présence
aujourd'hui parmi nous est importante et
nous en mesurons le prix quelles que
soient les différences d'appréciation
qui parfois souvent d'ailleurs nous
sépare dans les dossiers quotidien
avant-hier de mémoire cher françois
baroin eric orsenna nous présentait tu
t'en souviens
comme les chevaliers du possible en nous
ça nous a plu smaller était content tout
d'un coup on sortait du camp bouillon de
vnpt et les chevaliers du possible dans
la réalité on sait sur tout nous sommes
des mécaniciens du quotidien nous sommes
simplement des praticiens et le
praticien c'est celui qui décide qui
décident parfois sous la mitraille c'est
lui qui décide mais qui laissait en même
temps de se documenter
c'est ça
boulot de maire c'est cela notre
vocation c'est cela notre passion
d'ailleurs
et c'est ce qui nous amène d'ailleurs
chaque jour à travailler avec les
services de l'état dont vous êtes selon
la formule le chef chef de l'état et
vous me permettrez à cette occasion
aussi à travers vous de saluer les
ministres de votre gouvernement ceux qui
ont participé aux travaux de notre
congrès comme ceux qui vous accompagnent
aujourd'hui en nombre et en qualité
je veux aussi et bien sûr et
chaleureusement
remercier de sa présence et de son
action au service des communes
inlassable action au service des
communes le président de la chambre des
communes le président du sénat gérard
larcher et je voudrais qu'on
l'applaudisse
[Applaudissements]
avec l'ensemble ses collègues sénateurs
et notamment ceux de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales il est
constamment à notre écoute à l'écouté de
nos communes dont il comprend à la fois
les difficultés les réalités mais aussi
des espérances
et je remercie enfin de leur présence
les collègues présidentes et présidents
d'associations d'élus du bloc communal
comme d autres strates avec lequel je
souhaite ardemment travailler et que la
mf poursuivre et amplifie sa coopération
pour dès que nous pourrons montrer une
voie unique ou un front uni à l'égard de
l'état pour faire entendre nos
aspirations aux libertés locales
territoire unis d'ailleurs cher françois
scheer gérard en est une belle et grande
et pertinente émanations expérience et
je travaillerai dans cet esprit avec
carole delga et françois sauvadet que je
salue également amicalement
alors mes chers collègues monsieur le
président vous me permettrez
comme nouveau président de l'association
des maires de france
d'exprimer pour la première fois
devant vous devant tous les maires ma
reconnaissance et ma gratitude
qu'il soit que nous soyons de métropole
ou d'autres mères je veux vous remercier
de m'avoir accordé de nous avoir accordé
largement votre confiance
nous ferons tout jeu pour nous en
montrer dignes avec l'équipe qui
m'entoure et cette équipe que nous
voulons soudé au service des mères avec
philippe laurent que je salue et nous
ferons tout pour représenter fidèlement
notre diversité
et puis parmi ces mères il ya deux mers
n'est plus tout à fait mais on reste
mère toute sa vie auquel je veux rendre
un hommage particulier
je le fais avec l'émotion je le fais
avec plaisir j'ai fait évidemment avec
sincérité je pense à jacques pélissard
je voudrais qu'on applaudit jacques
pélissard
qui m'a accordé sa confiance il ya plus
de 25 ans alors que je ne connaissais
personne dans cet univers mais j'étais
passionné de chose publique et ce qui
paraissait incongrue je voulais revenir
à l'époque dans ma ville de cannes pour
être maire de cannes s'est fait depuis
quelques années maintenant et jacques
pélissard avec qui j'ai fait mes
premières pas dans la vie
professionnelle publique puisque j'ai
essentiellement travaillé dans le privé
et dans le jura et qui fut que vous le
savez président l'association des maires
de france c'est pour moi un honneur que
de le savoir à mes côtés aujourd'hui ici
encore dans cette salle
et puis
je voudrais bien sûr
saluer là aussi avec beaucoup de
gratitude avec reconnaissance avec
admiration la confiance de françois
baroin
françois baroin
qui m'avait nommé vice président de la
nff et l'un des porte parole
est dans la lignée dans laquelle je
souhaite m'inscrire
françois baroin qui m'a apporté tout son
soutien toute sa confiance
il a été pendant sept ans notre
formidable président de l'association
des maires de france cela fut rappelé
tout à l'heure et il l'a été au plus
plus fort d'événements exceptionnels sur
à cheval sur deux quinquennats
de toute nature je pense évidemment au
terrorisme qui nous a et qui nous
marquent encore si violemment je pense
bien sûr à la baisse historique des
dotations de l'état qui ne sont pas des
subventions qui sont un argent qui
appartient et qui devrait appartenir en
tout cas aux collectivités et aux
communes je pense bien évidemment au
mouvement des gilets jaunes
ou les communes ont su tendre la main à
l'exécutif et à l'état je pense enfin
bien sûr à la crise du coc vide crise
dont nous ne sommes pas sortis nous
l'avons nous l'avons bien compris
françois baroin a toujours su défendre
libertés locales et la cause des mères
avec lui la cité avec précision avec
loyauté et vous me permettrez d'ajouter
avec une qualité qui pour moi incarne le
plus beau des esprits français le
panache et l'élégance
alors mes chers collègues
comme ce fut le cas d'ailleurs dans le
passé pour jacques pélissard je vous
propose après acceptation unanime du
bureau ce matin l'association des maires
de france
que nous lui décernons par acclamation
le titre de président d'honneur de
l'association des maires de france en
reconnaissance des services rendus à
l'association et à la france et
n'hésitez pas à vous lever
[Applaudissements]
c'est tellement mérité que de se lever
pour applaudir france à barran et en
plus c'est très bon pour la santé
dans ce temps de digestion
après déjà deux discours fort pertinent
et forêts le camp est le mien qui le
sera moins forcément et avant celui tant
attendu du président de la république
en 114 ans d'existence de la mf seuls
les guerres le terrorisme en 2015 et la
crise sanitaire en 2020
vous avez contrat a renoncé à nous
réunir alors c'est le 103e congrès eh
bien ça et celui des retrouvailles
en commun avec ce mot absolument moche
en présentiel on se retrouve quoi pour
de vrai à la vraie vie il y en eut
heureux
c'est son troisième congrès nous permet
d'accueillir pour la première fois la
nouvelle génération d'élus issus des
élections municipales de mars et juin
2020 et je veux les saluer en notre nom
collectif en votre nom à tous et les
remercier à leur participation en nombre
de travaux on a vu arriver cette
génération de maire élu dans des
conditions absolument à l'incroyable en
mars 2020 et nous sommes là à leurs
côtés pour s'ils en ont besoin beaucoup
n'ont pas besoin ils sont déjà
extrêmement aguerris de les accompagner
dans leur magnifique mandat le plus beau
mandat celui de maire
ces élus ont pris leurs fonctions je
lisais dans les circonstances et un
calendrier absolument exceptionnelle au
vrai sens du terme leur début de mandat
a été marqué par les contraintes de
gestion liés à la crise sanitaire par
l'incertitude sur l'avenir et tout ce
qui a accompagné la crise sanitaire la
crise économique la crise sociale cette
ambivalence qui consistait à protéger
les vies humaines sans perdre l'humanité
de la vie c'est ce que nous avons fait
dans nos communes heureusement que les
mères étaient là pour rappeler cette
exigence qu'une vie humaine ne vaut que
par son humanité par ses contacts par sa
proximité par sa solidarité par sa
générosité
c'est cela comporte et les maires de
france pendant cette crise
et puis je tiens aussi à rendre un
hommage spécifiques
à nos collègues maires adjoints et
conseillers municipaux qui ne devait
plus être aux affaires après mars 2020
et qui ont été prolongées qui ont
continué d'assurer leurs responsabilités
avec beaucoup de dignité et
d'implication leurs responsabilités
municipales et intercommunales alors
même qu'il n'avait pas été candidat à
leur renouvellement ou que l' issue des
urnes en avait décidé autrement ils sont
restés fidèles au poste comme toujours
avec les maires eh bien je veux vraiment
aussi les saluer ils nous regardent
certainement à distance et leur dire que
ils ont fait honneur au sens de
l'engagement de l'engagement local
[Applaudissements]
ainsi et du sortant nouveaux élus chacun
à contribuer au fonctionnement
ininterrompu qui est une des marques de
fabrique et de grandeur du vrai service
public de nos collectivités et garanties
précisément cette continuité des
services rendus à la population
j'évoque évidemment à ce stade mes chers
collègues la crise sanitaire
depuis mars 2020 parfois d'ailleurs
depuis février puisque certaines mairies
avaient commencé à doter en masquer
certains agents exposé depuis février
les communes ont pris toute leur part ça
a été évoqué à la gestion quotidienne de
cette crise elle continue de prendre
leur part à la gestion quotidienne de
cette crise elles sont allées d'ailleurs
au delà de leur champ de compétence
habituelle en étant disponible réactive
incarné est capable de s'adapter en
permanence
de façon pertinente et efficace
à tous les aléas que nous rencontrions
alors quel bilan pouvons nous tirer de
cette longue période
du point de vue des relations entre
l'état et les collectivités et du point
de vue d'ailleurs en général des
services rendus aux citoyens
les temps a naturellement concentrer la
responsabilité de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
puisque la santé publique chacun le sait
ici relève de sa compétence exclusive
alors quel que soit le jugement que
chacun porte sur les décisions prises
nous mesurons bien monsieur le président
la république le poids écrasant de cette
responsabilité
nous nous sommes interrogés dès le
premier jour de notre congrès sur les
enseignements que nous tirons à ce stade
de la gestion de la crise la crise
est un moment par définition qui doit
être provisoire
temporaire douloureux
la crise est aussi un accélérateur de
changement un catalyseur de transition
la crise
c'est ce pourquoi a été inventé la
politique la vraie au sens noble du
terme depuis que l'on sait que l'homme
est un loup pour l'homme
le sens de la politique le sens du
politique le sens de nos missions
respectives
c'est de protéger le groupe de projeter
le groupe est de faire en sorte que
collectivement nous puissions avancer
si il est vrai que l'exécutif a pris la
responsabilité des orientations
décisives pour lutter contre la pandémie
il est clair aussi que seul le concours
des collectivités locales les
collectivités territoriales a permis la
mise en oeuvre opérationnelle des
décisions les plus lourdes sur le plan
logistique
toutes les communes de france se sont
mobilisés dans ce sens
le premier constat que nous faisons est
celui de l'extrême centralisation pour
beaucoup d'entre nous c'était une
confirmation dans nos constats extrême
centralisation des décisions
y compris parfois au détriment de l'état
déconcentré lui même
combien de préfet
je me suis laissé dire parfois même deux
ministres ont découvert les décisions en
même temps que nous
et cela s'est traduit par de vraies
difficultés opérationnelles
on peut comprendre que les grandes
décisions sanitaires soient prises par
ceux qui en portent la responsabilité
devant le client hélas parfois devant
les juges aussi
mais nous avons eu à déployer et
beaucoup d'efforts et à déplorer dans de
nombreuses situations un manque de
coordination
les problèmes de faisabilité de mise en
oeuvre la gestion des protocoles
sanitaires à l'école en particulier ou
dans les ehpad par exemple à illustrer
cette absence de concertation en amont
plaçant les collectivités et les
professionnels devant le fait accompli
dans des délais qui parfois chacun le
reconnaissez y compris d'ailleurs les
représentants locaux de l'état
irréaliste
comme nous l'avons évoqué hier soir dans
votre bureau et m'a autorisé à évoquer
ses propos monsieur le président la
république et je veux vous remercier de
ce moment important dans ceux des coûte
que nous avons eu des échanges que nous
avons eus l'état et je pense que nous
partageons cette approche doit
indéniablement
améliorer son fonctionnement des
concentrés en laissant plus de marge de
manoeuvre à ceux qui le représentent sur
le terrain ayant les associations plus
en les associant plus pardon aux
décisions prises par les administrations
centrales
l'état local et parfois la première
victime de son propre excès de
centralisme et parfois de ses
contradictions internes j'y reviendrai
tout à l'heure et je pense en
particulier au préfet et au sous préfet
qui en sont parfois les premières
victimes le second constat
que nous tirons de cette crise et qu'il
y a urgence à ouvrir largement le débat
sur les choix de santé publique le
ministère de la santé et les hautes
autorités de santé ont mis leur énergie
dans cette lutte contre la pandémie
comme l'a fait d'ailleurs l'ensemble des
personnels de santé acquis à nouveau
nous rendons hommage et à qui nous ne
rendrons jamais assez hommage pour leur
dévouement leur compétence leur
abnégation
il ne pense qu'on peut les applaudir au
nom des maires de france
[Applaudissements]
ceci étant ce n'est pas faire injure au
ministère la santé quels que soient ceux
qui l'occupent que de dire que c'est ta
ministère d'économies c'est un ministère
de recherche de rationalisation que
c'est pas un ministère de logistique
et combien de maires ont témoigné nous
l'avons vu d'ailleurs ces dernières
heures ces derniers jours ne l'a vu le
avons vu d'elle depuis début de la crise
que ladite crise précisément a
malheureusement conforté la gestion
verticale et lointaines des enjeux de
santé par le seul ministère de la santé
trop souvent concentrés sur l'hôpital
parfois rigide dans son approche de la
médecine de ville et des relations
privées publiques
est il adapté aux défis logistiques
il a plus tarder à mobiliser autour de
lui les acteurs publics les acteurs
privés aussi et notamment du secteur de
la santé sur lesquels ils auraient pu
s'appuyer il aurait dû beaucoup plus
appuyé dans les premiers mois de la
crise
le ségur la santé auxquels nous avons
participé s'est concentrée sur la
situation des personnels et des
établissements publics ce qui peut se
comprendre et ce qui était nécessaire
mais a fait peu de place à nos
préoccupations d'organisation et de
maillage de notre système de santé
nous avons présenté surprise en la
république avec au nom des maires de
france trois propositions importantes
une plus forte territorialisation des
politiques de santé
un décloisonnement des offres sanitaire
médico social et social et troisièmement
une politique ambitieuse pour le grand
âge nous continuerons de porter ses
propositions dans le débat public car
nous souhaitons que le rôle des maires y
soit reconnu notamment pour ce qui
concerne la coordination de l'ensemble
des acteurs de santé qui intervient le
plan local
ainsi nous demandons que les maires
soient très étroitement associés aux
instances schéma ils sont tellement
nombreux et les schémas dans notre pays
contrats de santé ayant un impact sur
leur territoire comme les instances de
gouvernance des hôpitaux
d'abord une chose très simple en fait
tenant compte du retour d'expérience des
années qui viennent de s'écouler c'est
que nous ne soyons plus potiche dans les
conseils de surveillance mais que nous
soyons à nouveau président des conseils
d'administration des hôpitaux de france
nous demandons aussi avec régions de
france que et le débat prospère
actuellement y compris grâce à l'action
des sénateurs que les ars soit plus
intègres plus la gouvernance locale
j'aime pas tellement ce terme et cette
expression mais intègre bien sûr les
présidents de région mais également les
maires dans les instances décisionnelles
avec une véritable co présidence
alors même que l'accès aux soins ne
relève pas d'une compétence obligatoire
pour les communes mais andré laignel a
rappelé tout à l'heure à travers ce le
texte cette motion la pertinence de la
clause de compétence générale
les maires et prise en intercommunalité
démontre chaque jour leur fort
engagement pour me tenir sur leur
territoire une offre de soins de
proximité
l'offre de soins de proximité de qualité
à un coût supportable pour leur
administrer
la situation en beaucoup d'endroits est
grave et dépasse largement la capacité
d'initiative des élus en matière d'accès
aux soins une inégalité profonde se
creuse chaque jour davantage entre nos
habitants selon l'endroit où il réside
7 cette situation est incontestablement
le fruit d'une organisation actuelles et
anciennes d'ailleurs de notre système de
santé
la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
allons-nous définitivement accepté cette
tendance qui fini par concentrer l'offre
de soins dans les centres urbains et le
tour des grands hôpitaux
l'offre de soins ne restera pas un débat
de spécialistes
car c'est s'agit vraiment je sais
comment ce n'est tous convaincus ici
d'un enjeu majeur de politique publique
chaque citoyen est concerné et notamment
dans les secteurs ruraux mais pas
seulement dans les secteurs ruraux et
avec du pragmatisme lorsqu'un
application d'ailleurs du principe de
subsidiarité qui fait que lorsque le
marché ne peut pas répondre aux besoins
lorsque le service public d'état est
absent et bien c'est à l'initiative le
câble suffit tu pourquoi pas envisager
d'avoir des médecins salariés par des
collectivités territoriales dans
certains secteurs je crois que cette
question là doit être posée très
sérieusement aujourd'hui les maires de
france
interpellé sans cesse sur cette question
veulent que les choses bougent et que
des décisions soient prises devraient
décision pour garantir une offre de
proximité
nous sommes volontaires monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres pour participer à ce débat qui
ne manquera pas de s'ouvrir je l'espère
en tout cas à nouveau dans les mois qui
viennent et qui renvoie à la question
fondamentale de la décentralisation
dans les semaines et les mois prochains
l'association des maires de france
preuve précisera ses propositions en
matière de décentralisation françois
baroin en a exprimé un certain nombre
hier il faut encore qu'elle soit celle
de l'ensemble des maires de france mais
nous y travaillerons jeu puis en prendre
l'engagement ici en matière de
décentralisation ces enjeux de santé
publique nous rappelle que toutes les
politiques publiques sont désormais
partagés entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales
c'est même inscrit d'ailleurs dans la
constitution de la france les raisons
sont multiples mais cette situation
traduit le caractère inachevé de notre
décentralisation qui ne peut pas
fonctionner sans une répartition plus
claire des compétences
nous sommes au bout du rafistolage
la décentralisation est le fruit d'une
volonté politique longtemps évoquée par
le général de gaulle par le grand
président pompidou par valéry giscard
d'estaing est concrétisé par le
président mitterrand et à travers son
ministre de l'intérieur gaston defferre
qui à un moment donné avait pris le
contre-pied de tous les principes qui
avait façonné l'organisation
administrative de notre pays
après 40 ans d'expérience de succès
mais aussi parfois de retour en arrière
nous pouvons faire le constat que dans
notre pays la décentralisation n'est pas
abouti nous disions dans notre
résolution que dans certains domaines
elles reculent même
nous connaissons vos réserves sur
l'esprit de noël 1982 qui ne vous semble
plus correspondre à la situation de
notre pays aujourd'hui je vous ai
entendu les exprimer lors du grand débat
pour vous l'état doit fixer les grandes
orientations de ce plan la république et
les collectivités sur la pour les mettre
en oeuvre évidemment nous ne contestons
nullement parce que nous sommes des
dépositaires aussi et des agents de
l'état est tout simplement des citoyens
la prééminence de l'état dans ses
missions régaliennes surtout en france
la france est constituée dans sa colonne
vertébrale
administrative par cette farce de l'état
et des communes rejointe par les
départements
donc bien au contraire nous appelons
même à ce que l'état retrouve toute son
autorité son autorité notamment
régaliennes à travers ses missions outre
de d'armes et de diplomatie mais de
justice et de police au sens large du
terme et je sais que des travaux ont été
engagés en la matière nous en parlions
tout à l'heure avec monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur mise de l'intérieur
nous constatons simplement que l'état
dans la réalité n'est plus capable
d'exercer la plupart des missions de
proximité au service de la population
parce qu'il n'a plus ni l'effectif sur
le terrain ni de moyens sur le
territoire ce qui est un paradoxe dans
une époque qui nous voient à battre
depuis des années d'assurance pas
nouveau le record des prélèvements
obligatoires avec une fonction publique
qui n'a jamais été aussi mauvaise mais
jamais aussi peu présente sur le
territoire et sur certains aspects de
notre territoire
parce que
vous n'hésitez pas à applaudir
ça fera une pause bon j'ai pris ma
famille un verre d'eau si verdu voilà
n'hésitez pas à applaudir nous voulons
de la fonction publique locale
merci de votre indulgence
et il est vrai que les réorganisations
successives de ses services déconcentrés
au gré des quinquennats ont conduit à la
disparition de services
locaux et services des préfectures sont
souvent réduits au minimum et les sous
préfectures ne parviennent plus dans
certains secteurs à ouvrir tous les
jours au public est une réalité
constatée
cet état là ne peut plus rendre les
pardons prétendre rendre les mêmes
services au public auparavant c'est un
constat factuel
c'est ainsi il faut en tirer les
conséquences car en france d'ailleurs
comme en europe il existe une forte
aspiration des peuples à ce que les
décisions qui les concernent directement
dans leur vie quotidienne soit prise au
plus près d'eux or nous constatons trop
souvent le contraire sur le terrain cela
a commencé par la suppression des
services isolé peu fréquentées dans les
communes et les cantons
cela a continué avec l'allègement de
réseaux départementaux entier comme la
plus récente réorganisation des
trésoreries
cela s'est parfois traduit aussi par le
transfert de l'échelon régional pour
notre enfer pardon à l'échelon régional
que nous évoquions aussi d'ailleurs hier
soir pour conserver une taille critique
une certaine expertise je vais là dessus
dire quelque chose selon une certaine
imprécations administrative qui consiste
à penser
systématiquement que plus c'est gros
plus c'est efficace
vision dogmatique
qui ont abandonné contrairement à ce
qu'on nous raconte tous les jours nombre
d'entreprises dans le management
entrepreneurial dans l'organisation des
entreprises il ya des tailles critiques
à atteindre bien sûr pour passer la
commande publique bien sûr pour des ddd
gestion et des fonctions support des
fonctions ressources mais dans les
entreprises depuis longtemps maintenant
nous savons que l'efficacité elle dépend
de l'incarnation et de la proximité donc
cessons de penser que la rationalité
c'est toujours de construire des grands
machins parce que ce n'est pas vrai
et de ce point de vue là
les lois notre une autre et selon qu'on
les qualifie et mccann aurait déjà été
un peu toiletté elle mériterait d'être
un peu plus réajuster
ce que démontre l'action quotidienne des
mères c'est que la proximité
créé la responsabilité et que la
responsabilité est source d'efficacité
mais pour qui les responsabilités
d'ailleurs c'était mon propos liminaire
encore faut-il qu'il y ait liberté
liberté d'action liberté d'être et en
l'occurrence nous sommes ici au congrès
des maires de france il s'agit de
libertés locales donc de façon plus
technique de décentralisation et de
subsidiarité
et c'est pourquoi nous portons depuis
plusieurs années ici au sein de
l'association des maires de france le
projet d'un approfondissement de la
décentralisation j'allais dire d'une
relance de la décentralisation de ce
nouveau souffle décentralisateur évoqué
dans notre résolution il s'agit pour
nous
d'achever le transfert de
responsabilités des politiques publiques
du quotidien vers les collectivités
territoriales nous avons beaucoup mis en
avant cette revendication
aussi bien au nom de la mf que dans le
cadre de territoire unis
d'autres associations d'élus que j'ai
salué tout à l'heure ont aussi évoqué
cette perspective dans leur première
contribution au débat présidentiel ne
le faisons pas par défiance à l'égard de
l'état et c'est vraiment le message que
je veux vous faire passer aujourd'hui à
toutes et tous comme on dit dans le
nouveau monde nous ne le faisons pas par
calcul politique
nous ne faisons pas par effet de manche
accordez-nous que nous puissions avoir
des convictions des convictions tirés de
notre vécu tirés de notre expérience la
demande de liberté locale n'a jamais été
aussi forte et les libertés locales
n'ont jamais été autant nécessaire
elles n'ont jamais été autant nécessaire
pour deux raisons principales d'une part
il existe dans notre pays une défiance
croissante à l'égard des décisions
d'autorité lointaine verticale et non
préparé
le mouvement des gilets jaunes à
illustrer ce vide de vertigineux entre
certains citoyens et toutes les formes
de pouvoir toutes les formes de pouvoir
d'autre part
l'état
ne pourra pas
retisser seul ce lien de confiance et je
sais que vous le savez qui a été abîmée
durablement nos collectivités peuvent
apporter une visibilité de l'action
publique de chaque citoyen mais pour
réussir
nous avons besoin elles ont besoin ces
collectivités publiques de pouvoir
exercer pleinement leurs responsabilités
donc de liberté d'action enfin
la demande de liberté locale s'est
renforcée parce que depuis longtemps les
administrations centrales on agit pour
reprendre une partie du pouvoir qu'elle
avait perdue par la loi et ce mouvement
est constant parfois insidieux elles ont
un cadre est chaque jour un peu plus
l'action de nos collectivités aussi bien
par la réduction de notre autonomie
fiscale qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure
que par la remise en cause permanente de
compétences décentralisées majeur je
pense entre autres compétences
d'urbanisme je prépare les aussi du
logement je prépare les longuement des
lois sru allure et autres
d'ailleurs en matière de logement la
notion de contrat de mixité sociale
proposée par le sénat chargée rares
monsieur le président pardon est
certainement une première façon de
sortir par lot de l'impasse d'un
actuelle dans laquelle nous sommes dans
les zones tendues et j'espère que les
évolutions législatives de la loi très
ds
permettront soit en cmp fois par
acclamation de l'assemblée nationale de
reprendre les travaux du sénat en la
matière
les élus que nous sommes nous vivons
tous les jours ce mouvement ce mouvement
de recentralisation je sais que
vous nous avons évoqué hier soir vous
vous exprimerez de la façon dont vous
pensez que cas contraire il ya un
mouvement de décentralisation nous nous
constatons dans l'opérationnalité ce
mouvement de recentralisation
juste un exemple y compris dans les
dispositions des plans de relance aux
autres la multiplication des appels à
projet il n'y a pas une assemblée
départementale de mr ben amer avec qui
je parle est pas moins un constat que je
fais dans ma commune qui n'évoque ses
appels à projets autant on comprend que
l'état impulsent des politiques
publiques que l'état agisse en effet de
levier outre la péréquation verticale
qui doit assumer pour assurer l'égalité
territoriale la justice en tout cas
territoriale l'équité territoriale à
laquelle nous sommes tous très attachés
autant la façon dont les appels à
projets sont lancés avec des délais
extrêmement courts avec une bureaucratie
comme souvent extrêmement pointilleuse
élimine dé facto une grande partie des
communes de france et de certaines
intercommunalités de la capacité de
s'inscrire dans une dynamique
territoriale
après la projet as alors il ya aussi les
fameux ami
ça fait partie de nombreux acronyme qui
font la joie de notre quotidien
les rédacteurs des textes en eux j'ai
toujours trouvé une très très grande
capacité créatrice a créé des acronymes
pour faire votre local à poubelles il
faut respecter le pays lui-même conforme
au pea d'aidé qui doit être respectueux
en application du scot quand ils
existent qui lui-même se met en
application de la dt à tous dans le
respect du sras dette et du pea la chine
lorsqu'il a été adopté
derrière
derrière leurs douces sonorités
tous ces acronymes ont une réalité
contraignante chronophage
consommatrice de forêt même par le
papier qu'elles produisent
nous espérons
à la tête de l'état que le chef de
l'état quel qu'il soit évidemment ce
propos est un propos qui s'adresse de
façon respectueuse et cordiale au chef
de l'état que ceux qui produisent tous
ces acronymes et tous ces schémas et la
même créativité pour simplifier alléger
rendre possible ce qui est nécessaire
selon la bonne formule enrichie mieux
et c'est pourquoi
mes chers collègues
nous porterons clairement dans le débat
présidentiel
la démarche d'une clarification de
l'exercice des compétences du quotidien
pour ce qui relève déjà des compétences
communales et intercommunales
il nous faut retrouver une véritable
liberté d'action et mettre fin aux
contraintes réglementaires qui ne sont
que des prétextes à l'encadrement de
notre action pour ce qui concerne les
compétences du quotidien toujours dans
lesquelles l'état a gardé une place
prépondérante comme le logement le sport
ou la culture nous demanderons que soit
engagée une concertation sur un partage
différent de ses compétences entre
l'état et nous le logement je le disais
une des préoccupations majeures des
français avec des situations humaines
très douloureuse très difficile pour
beaucoup d'entre nous d'entre nous
beaucoup de nos compatriotes
nos compatriotes doivent pouvoir
librement choisir de se loger là ils le
souhaitent et l'offre doit être adapté à
toutes les catégories de revenus c'est
une liberté réelle pour reprendre un
vocable qui perd et andré laignel
fondamental c'est aussi une condition de
me la mobilité professionnelle et de
l'emploi pour répondre efficacement à
cette demande il nous faut raisonner en
bassin de vie et non dans un schéma
national des employés depuis le haut les
conditions d'application dans les lois
sru allure et autres ne sont simplement
pas compatible avec la réalité locale
nous l'évoquions tout à l'heure dans de
nombreuses communes malgré
systématiquement la bonne volonté des
maires et si les maires pouvaient ne pas
stigmatiser quand ils n'ont pas la
capacité tout de suite de répondre aux
injonctions sur la loi sru je pense que
vous feriez un grand progrès dans
l'apaisement des relations entre l'état
et les villes
quand dans votre commune
70 % de votre territoire fait l'objet d'
apporter la connaissance de l'état qui à
juste titre interdit toute construction
parce qu'il ya eu un phénomène majeur ou
ensuite de ppr y est que les 30%
restants sont déjà urbanisées et que
parallèlement on vous dit on vous
interdit de construire mais que
parallèlement en vous un jeu on vous
envoie selon ces injonctions
contradictoires auquel nous sommes hélas
habitués de construire des centaines de
logements vous faisant en plus une
petite donne une leçon de morale comme
disait nietzsche une petite injection de
moraline ont tout en vous disant de ne
pas faire d'effet de ghettoïsation on
crée de la défiance
on crée de l'énervement on crée de
l'agacement dont on pourrait se passer
les communes et les intercommunalités
doivent non seulement disposer des
outils financiers et fiscaux de soutien
à la construction et il ya une reprise
dans la construction
et c'est une bonne chose et il est vrai
qu'après l'année horribilis que nous
avons vécu c'était nécessaire mais aussi
d'une grande liberté d'adaptation des
règles nationales d'urbanisme aux
réalités du territoire c'est tout ce que
nous demandons que ces règles soient
adaptées à nos réalités et nous serons
les meilleurs partenaires vous pouvez
l'imaginer je le disais l'année 2020 a
marqué une chute historique de la
construction
c'est peut-être l'occasion aujourd'hui
d'évaluer le dispositif réglementaire
financier et fiscal de notre politique
du logement pour y faire entrer un
concept essentiel un concept
constitutionnel et pas seulement
essentiel celui de la subsidiarité
naturellement
il ne servirait à rien d'approfondir la
décentralisation si on ne voyait pas
dans le même temps à redonner de la
liberté de gestion de la responsabilité
de la capacité d'initiative à nos
communes et à leurs intercommunalités
c'est pourquoi dans les débats qui vont
s'ouvrir et bien nous continuerons de
placer et de plaider pardon pour un
assouplissement des règles des règles de
fonctionnement de l'intercommunalité
alors il ne s'agit pas comme je les
entends dû parfois dire pour dénigrer
les positions les meufs injustement
comme souvent comme toujours de
détricoter ce qui existe il s'agit
simplement
de permettre à chaque alter communalité
de choisir librement le mode
d'organisation des compétences qui lui
semble le mieux adapté à la situation
c'est le sens des dispositions qui ont
été votées par le sénat récemment et que
nous soutenons il nous faut
cesser d'agir comme si
l'intercommunalité été menacé sur son
principe est que seule une vitrification
de ses règles de fonctionnement la
protègerait c'est un réflexe
technocratique jacobins et donc par
définition dépasser la proche
pragmatiques comme toujours pertinentes
à laquelle je crois est celle de la
solidarité
l'intercommunalité de noix pas y faire
exception mais c'est à nous et lui
d'assumer leur responsabilité
de choisir comment les choses doivent se
passer concrètement de ne pas
marginaliser des maires dans les
intercommunalités au camer ne doit se
sentir relégué dans sa capacité
décisionnelle au sein des
intercommunalités
de la liberté de la responsabilité il
enfin aussi dans la maîtrise des grands
enjeux locaux je pense en particulier à
la mise en oeuvre de la transition
écologique et à l'aménagement du
territoire il est tout à fait normal
nécessaire pertinent que l'état élabore
et fassent connaître les grands
objectifs qu'il fixe en la matière et de
ce point de vue là les dispositions
récentes sont pertinentes mais cela ne
doit pas conduire à une dépossession de
notre capacité d'action et d'initiative
ne plus travailler en silo ce qui vaut
aussi pour les collectivités
territoriales
nous l'avions évoqué aussi monsieur le
président la république hier soir m'a
fait l'honneur de me convier dans votre
bureau et nous avons pu échanger
présence de françois en toute liberté
ce don vraiment je vous sais gré vous
remercier nous avons
évoqué le grand souffle décentralisateur
que les emf appelle de ses voeux et
continuera d'appeler de ses voeux dans
les prochaines années j'y reviendrai je
vous ai indiqué des mesures en attendant
ce grand soupe décentralisateur qui
pourraient être prises tout de suite
dans cette fin de quinquennat
pour servir les maires et moi je ne
manque pas une occasion de le faire
passer le message ce que j'ai fait hier
soit est ce que j'ai fait à nouveau
aujourd'hui
et je vous ai indiqué quelques mesures
immédiates qui peuvent et qui bien sûr
pour nous qui doivent être prises pour
régler les problèmes du moment et
renforcer la confiance entre les écuries
fait nos communes et que nous nous
sentions respecter
et pas flatté
je vous ai parlé des aspirations
suivante et je suis sûr que vous les
avez entendus pour certaines d'entre
elles et que tout à l'heure vous nous
indiquera comment vous souhaitez y
répondre tout d'abord l'objectif de zéro
artificialisation net fameuse anne
qui ne rendent pas toujours zen le jeu
de mots est pas terrible vont pardonner
than qui descend d'un seul bloc sur le
document d'urbanisme
dans un calendrier irréaliste
nous sommes tous attachés à la
biodiversité et la lutte contre la part
anthropique du réchauffement climatique
et à la lutte contre les particules
fines aussi jeudi au passage mais le
principe de réalité doit toujours
prévaloir
nous veillerons bien sûr une partie
finalisées des sols c'est un objectif
que moi mais j'ai longtemps défendu mais
cela ne peut pas être fait de cette
façon verticale monolithique et surtout
et surtout dans des délais irréalistes
retravaillé tous les documents
d'urbanisme y compris les fameux sera
dead scott etc d'ici février et nous
mettre dans une impasse
opérationnel
incontournable donc nous vous demandons
après avoir contesté la façon dont la
loi y étaient fabriqués mais nous sommes
des républicains nous nous respectons la
loi de la république nous voulons
appliquer la loi république encore
faut-il que celle ci soit applicable de
repousser ce délai pour nous permettre
de mettre en adéquation avec les
subtilités de la loi et de l'objectif de
0 artifice à sion net la conception des
documents d'urbanisme qui doivent
accompagner nos prises de décision c'est
une demande opérationnel que nous vous
confirmons aujourd'hui
parce que
ce calendrier est irréaliste et il ne
correspond pas à ses enjeux nouveaux et
et c'est ainsi monsieur le président que
ce creed de toutes pièces les conflits
entre l'état les collectivités
c'est comme ça dans la réalité
territoriale que ça se passe tout le
monde personne ne doute des bonnes
intentions des uns et des autres donc si
ce délai est repoussé je pense que nous
pourrons avancer concrètement de même
aucun maire ne peut en même temps se
voir bloquée dans un projet de
rénovation de logements par un abf qui
lui interdira de m
ddd des fenêtres en pvc pour lutter
contre la déperdition de chaleur donc
dépossédé de ce pouvoir d'urbanisme et
puis parallèlement se voir imposer des
éoliennes sur sa commune
le sénat l'a compris il avait
réintroduit l'accord du maire dans la
loi mais l'assemblée nationale c'était
hier où avant-hier a préféré supprimer
cet accord conforme du maire que nous
demandons de nous veut au motif de
l'impératif développement des énergies
renouvelables car hâtif que nous
partageons ardemment et comme je voulais
exprimer hier soir
avec un exemple vécu que j'ai eu dans ma
commune où je me suis vu interdire après
avoir été lauréat d'un concours européen
soutenu par l'état est soutenu par le
préfet la commission des sites et la bf
en l'occurrence vu interdire d'installer
des panneaux solaires sur des
équipements de traitement des déchets
qui était près d'un site classé et
parallèlement je me verrais interdire
d'installer un panneau solaire mais je
vous pourrez voir imposer un champ
d'éoliennes c'est pas possible voilà
c'est aussi simple que cela et nous
voulons là dessus que mes compétences
d'urbanisme soient reconnus
parce que agir telle qu'elle s'est
présentée le maire comme un obstacle
comme celui ou celle qui ne comprend pas
les enjeux de la transition énergétique
que seuls des esprits éclairés militants
ou mercantiles pourrait comprendre la
maîtrise de l'aménagement de nos
territoires est un principe essentiel de
la décentralisation dans le respect des
compétences de chaque niveau de
collectivité comme je le disais
avant-hier
de même que
l'instruction publique apporte aux
individus l'égalité des chances
l'aménagement du territoire apporte aux
territoires légalité des capacités de
développement
et
je vous ai également alerté hier soir
sur le cas des 14 9 communes forestières
qui se retrouvent face là aussi une
sorte de contradiction une forte
qu'annoncée partie figurez-vous une
forte augmentation des contributions du
budget de l'eau nf pour les raisons que
l'on sait
et parallèlement à la diminution de 500
agents de cette même veine f je vous
remercie de votre écoute sur ce point et
nous attendons là aussi bien évidemment
votre parole
cet enjeu mes chers collègues et les
communes forestières applaudi dans la
salle elles ont raison cet enjeu mes
chers collègues de liberté de
responsabilité
est aussi au centre des problématiques
fiscales et financières de nos
collectivités nous faisons tous le
constat d'un dépouillement progressif de
nos ressources propres et d'un
démantèlement continue de la fiscalité
locale depuis une douzaine d'années taxe
professionnelle taxe d'habitation impôt
économique taxe d'électricité menaces
sur les faire radio la liste est longue
et des coups portés à nos marges de
manoeuvre fiscales les produits fiscaux
locaux sont progressivement remplacées
par des dotations ou départ d'impôts
nationaux et ensuite on nous dit à
regarder ces mères ils sont pleurnichard
ils demandent des notations non on
demande que l'argent qui appartient aux
tribus lab locaux reviennent aux
contribuables locaux et en l'occurrence
communaux
les contribuables nationale remplace au
contribuable local pour financer les
services publics locaux
cette évolution elle n'est pas saine
n'est pas bonne parce qu'elle se fait au
détriment du lien civique que constitue
le consentement à l'impôt et je crois
que ce qui devrait nous interpeller tous
y compris dans les débats d'ailleurs
nationaux c'est cette dévitalisation au
civic que l'on constate à travers soi
des expressions fantaisistes ou
extrémiste soit à travers l'abstention
que nous constatons partout
cette évolution est en outre un
instrument de recentralisation et de
reprise en main des moyens financiers à
la disposition de l'échelon local
les dotations dans la durée qui s'avère
toujours inférieur aux recettes qu'elles
sont censées compenser comme l'ont
démontré tous les travaux en la matière
reste à la main de l'état dépendantes
chaque année du vote du budget désormais
33 % des recettes de fonctionnement des
communes et sont dépendantes en moyenne
parfois c'est beaucoup plus la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation est
la dernière étape de la déstabilisation
totale de notre système fiscal local le
système de compensation retenue qui fait
supporter aux communes rurales le
financement de la compensation des
communes urbaines et qui transfère une
part de l'effort fait sur par les
contribuables d'un territoire vers un
autre n'a aucune chance de survivre très
longtemps sans susciter contre lui une
forte opposition nous l'avons exprimé
tout à l'heure je tiens à le confirmer
aujourd'hui ce chantier un chantier
complexe y compris pour nous au sein des
communes est devant nous et cela
d'autant plus que la nationalisation de
la taxe d'habitation a aussi des
conséquences sur le calcul des dotations
rend encore plus complexe les mécanismes
de répartition au final les critères
d'attribution s'éloigneront la réalité
économique et sociale territoriale
l'association des maires de france sera
phase de proposition et de débats pour
une remise à plat de la fiscalité locale
et du calcul des dotations
il nous faut par exemple revoir les
inégalités financières et fiscales que
subissent beaucoup de secteurs
géographiques fragile je pense notamment
aux secteurs ruraux aux collectivités
d'outre-mer et aux quartiers les plus
pauvres notre système est à bout de
souffle afin avoir été réparé et
rafistolé au fil des années en
affaiblissant chaque fois un peu plus sa
cohérence ils nous font
de la visibilité dans nos ressources
pour pouvoir agir dans la durée et pour
investir et c'est pourquoi nous
proposerons au prochain gouvernement la
mise en oeuvre d'un pacte financier et
fiscal de législature qui pourrait
prendre la forme d'une loi de
programmation
nous sommes très lucide sur ce qui nous
attend dans les prochains mois je pense
à la réalité des comptes publics et
notamment de l'état nous sommes dans une
période de sortie de crise d'effet de
relance mais nous savons indéniablement
quel que soit ce qu'ils ont la
responsabilité de l'exécutif en france
qu'il y aura un moment donné une facture
à rembourser nous avons vu la dette
augmenter depuis 56 ans 50 milliards
d'euros la dette publique et les
déficits de l'état augmenté y compris
sur les parts non qu'ovide donc nous
serons très vigilants je dois le dire
ici solennellement nous serons très
vigilants sur le respect de l'intégrité
financière des communes au cours des
prochains mois et au cours des
prochaines années
nous serons très vigilants
mais nous serons aussi phase de
propositions parce que nous avons envie
d'agir nous avons besoin d'agir et
nouveau alors avoir la capacité d'agir
notre pays est à la fois riche
d'immenses talents d'immenses
d'initiatives mais aussi malheureusement
compte des doutes sur lui-même sous
nôtres payés souvent fracturée nous
l'avons vu pendant le confinement
notamment
nous avons évoqué tout à l'heure les
investigations médicales nous avons vu
les difficultés des hôpitaux nous avons
vu les difficultés dans les ehpad et
nous connaissons les disparités
territoriales être jeune en milieu rural
c'est formidable mais c'est pas toujours
une chance se forme et se cultiver
trouver du travail c'est plus compliqué
qu'ailleurs est une réalité les français
des espaces ruraux sont des
contribuables comme les autres il n'y a
aucune raison de les servir moins bien
et nous serons force de proposition à la
matière c'est depuis toujours mes chers
collègues une préoccupation de la mf et
cela va continuer et nous allons même
faire de cette problématique de la
reconnaissance de la réalité d'une des
grandes causes de la ms dans les
prochaines années nous avons envie
d'agir nous avons besoin d'agir en
outre-mer aussi les communes l'outre-mer
sont confrontés à des défis immenses
avec des moyens parfois dérisoires nous
devons d'avoir adapté massivement nos
dispositifs nationaux à leurs
particularités à leurs charges
financières et sociales aux catastrophes
naturelles qui les fera plus qu'ailleurs
à la sécurité qui de mamoudzou à
courroux de pointe à pitre à saint-denis
se renforce chaque jour un peu plus
l'outre-mer est une chance pour notre
pays
l'outre-mer dû donner un rayonnement
mondial et représente un enjeu
géostratégique économique est un enjeu
culturel
alors certes être jeune en outre mer
c'est formidable communes rurales et
c'est plus difficile qu'ailleurs pour
trouver du travail se former et accéder
à toutes les opportunités qu'offre la
france d'outre-mer doit être écoutée
comprise accompagné soutenu la mfr en ce
temps dans ces sept principaux
territoires elle va faire entendre cette
voix singulière et j'entends à ce titre
renforcer la mission outre-mer de la mf
pour venir en soutien permanent des
associations départementales et des
communes ultramarines qui connaissent
des situations très spécifiques et
pourquoi pas voir aussi tiens un détail
autres acronymes que les cdp naf en
outre-mer passe par un avis simple comme
en métropole et non plus que par un avis
conforme
nous avons envie d'agir monsieur le
président la république nous avons
besoin d'agir et nous voulons avoir la
capacité d'agir aussi pour les
territoires ce que d'aucuns appellent en
tout cas les territoires oubliés de la
république
il ya beaucoup de talents au moins
autant qu'ailleurs mais aussi beaucoup
plus de handicap nous en comptons
beaucoup à l'aef de ces maires de
banlieues qui s'épuise à la tâche en
première ligne à charles ix à surmonter
les difficultés
ils demandent que l'on aborde les
contradictions fondamentales de la
situation dans laquelle se trouve leur
quartier comment répondre aux besoins
plus importants en équipement des
populations plus jeunes a fait cap à
faible capacité fiscale avec des
ressources fiscales je disais plus
faibles pourquoi affecter des agents
publics peu expérimenté dans les
services publics plus difficile à gérer
la mf avait fortement soutenu le travail
de jean louis borloo fruit d'une
concertation très large qui reste une
référence et nous continuerons d'agir
dans ce sens pour faire entendre la voix
des villes et des banlieues
les maires s'engagent pour leur commune
ils le font très souvent au détriment de
leur vie quotidienne de leur vie
personnelle de leur vie personnelle nous
le faisons par choix nous faisons par
passion du bien public nous faisons
parce que c'est notre mission ils
peuvent le faire aussi hélas parfois au
péril de leur intégrité physique ou
morale il le faut aussi parfois au péril
de leur vie nous avons évoqué tout à
l'heure le souvenir douloureux dans
notre collègue varois
décédé il ya plusieurs mois nous
constatons
en dépit des efforts qui ont été
demandés au parquet que très souvent les
classes les palets parquet classe
massivement les plaintes ne poursuivent
pas toujours des infractions les parcs
étiez sont débordés font un superbe
travail très souvent mais manque de
moyens et nous attendons avec impatience
de voir les évolutions que se
concrétisait telles qu'elles ont été
annoncées récemment
les maires constate aussi qu'ils sont
soumis à un risque juridique toujours
plus aléatoire ils sont ensuivies avec
diligence par la justice parfois juste
judiciaire je ne reviens pas sur ce qui
a été évoqué sur la notion de prise
illégale d'intérêt mais cette
qualification pénale claire on voit un
risque de prise illégale d'intérêt
direct indirect moral est tellement
floue callen devient aléatoire et
qu'elle en devient arbitraire alors
évidemment
là dessus le problème d'un maire sait
que c'est un citoyen
parmi des citoyens mandaté par les
citoyens et que sa légitimité sa force
réside dans sa notoriété dans sa
réputation est une réputation entachée
même lorsqu'elle est lavé au bout de
quelques années l'affaiblît dans sa
capacité d'action est tout simplement
c'est extrêmement douloureux à vivre
pour un certain nombre de maires qui
nous ont fait part de mise en examen
induit parfois de condamnation tout à
fait injuste dans leurs actions
quotidiennes s'agit pas du tout de se
soustraire à la justice surtout pas il
s'agit simplement d'avoir une justice
clair une justice net une justice
efficace
alors monsieur le président la
république mesdames et messieurs les
maires mes chers collègues
oui nous battons depuis des années pour
que l'action des maires soient reconnus
pour qu'on facilite l'action des maires
et des adjoints et des conseillers
municipaux qu'ils soient reconnus dans
leur capacité
concrètes local de pouvoir agir et cela
ne se fera que par des mesures concrètes
cela se fera que par un grand souffle
décentralisateur chacun le sait comme
cela a été exprimé tout à l'heure les
mêmes aspire à un grand mouvement
décentralisateur à une grande loi des
libertés locales un profond renouveau
civique dont la condition réside dans la
clarté des institutions et l'efficacité
de l'action publique la subsidiarité
notre coeur de l'efficacité de la
collision dans les prochaines années
voilà ce que pourrait être une feuille
de route une sorte de pré manuela usage
du président ou de la présidente de la
république dans les prochaines années
l'association des maires de france
saura-t-elle un partenaire être pardon
un partenaire loyal de l'état exigeant
et loyal loyal car libre car la loyauté
n'existe que dans la liberté et non pas
dans la vassalité nous aspirons à un
état
qu'ils viennent au grand équilibre et à
la justice
nous aspirons à un état qui soit un
partenaire des collectivités locales
c'est dans c'est cela que nous proposons
monsieur le président la république
cette loyauté et la condition des
relations de confiance que nous
veillerons à établir elle doit être
réciproque dans un esprit de respect et
une volonté de sortir du conformisme qui
comme le révolutionnarisme est le
principal écueil de nos démocraties
indéniablement est hélas nous l'avons
évoqué nos communes ont été vite alizés
et des communes dévitalisées c'est une
france déprécier c'est une france
déclassé et c'est souvent une france
déprimé
et c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs pour
revitaliser cela je propose que la mg l
soit partenaire du parlement de
l'exécutif pour travailler en amont sur
les textes de loi qui concerne
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics et
veiller à ce que la fabrication de la
loi tiennent plus compte de nos réalités
locales et que nous soyons plus face à
des textes de lois ou des textes
réglementaires totalement hors sol
monsieur le président la république
il suffirait simplement que l'état
renonce à la prétention d'être seul pour
que tout pour que très vite
ils
soient accompagnés par toutes les
collectivités territoriales de france
monsieur le président la république il
suffirait simplement que l'état renonce
à la prétention notre tout pour que très
vite il cesse d'être seule une france
qui retrouve la subsidiarité une france
qui retrouve les énergies locales c'est
une france qui retrouve son espérance
cette espérance nous voulons la porte et
vive les communes de france vit
l'association des maires de france nue
la république
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président du sénat
mesdames et messieurs les ministres le
président du conseil économique social
et environnemental
monsieur le commissaire au plan mesdames
et messieurs les parlementaires
ce préfet de région
monsieur le président de l'association
des maires de france hier david lisnard
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
bureau et du comité directeur madame la
maire de paris
mesdames et messieurs les présidentes et
présidents d'associations d'élus locaux
mesdames et messieurs les élus mesdames
et messieurs chers amis
j'ai conscience que beaucoup de choses
ont été dites
[Applaudissements]
et peut-être se peut-il que je sois
néanmoins par courtoisie contraint de
revenir sur beaucoup de sujets
précédemment évoqué
j'appelle donc à votre indulgence et je
tâcherai d'être efficace ça sent aussi
que plusieurs d'entre vous ont des
contraintes très logistique pour la fin
de journée
je veux d'abord et ce n'est pas
simplement une formule de courtoisie
mais l'esprit républicain
félicité les nouveaux membres du bureau
de votre association et vous féliciter
monsieur le président cher david de
votre élection dit hier je vous adresse
tous mes voeux de succès à titre
personnel et tous mes voeux de succès
pour l'association compte tenu de
l'importance de celle-ci bravo
[Applaudissements]
je veux féliciter tous vos colistiers
celles et ceux qui poursuivent dans
leurs responsabilités précédentes ou et
acquérir de nouvelles responsabilités à
vos côtés et je sais que vous aurez à
coeur de cultiver cet esprit qui est
propre à la mf et qui a été plusieurs
fois ici évoquer saluer et qui a animé
vos prédécesseurs jean paul delevoye
daniel hoeffel jacques pélissard ici
présents et que je salue amicalement
pour sa présence parmi nous
cher jacques
et depuis 2014
françois baroin et je veux ici remerciée
pour son sens de l'intérêt général et
son action à la tête de l'association
françois baroin pour cette année
je tiens aussi à saluer philippe laurent
et l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui ont
proposé un autre projet à gogo tu es qui
pour certains vous ont rejoint au sein
des instances lui qui a pendant été de
nombreuses années à la fois secrétaire
général puis vice président et dont je
peux témoigner et doivent philippe comme
jean castex à leur tour de
l'indépendance d'esprit du sens du
devoir et de sa capacité à défendre
aussi l'ensemble des mères
[Applaudissements]
au total
l'important est aujourd'hui que l'unité
le plus le pluralisme
l'indépendance de votre association soit
pleinement préservée assumer loin de
tous les débats qui sont légitimes et
qui animent la vie démocratique de notre
pays mais qui ne doivent pas ici venir
entraver la bonne marche de nos communes
et de l'action publique partout en
france j'y suis pour ma part très
attaché
alors nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui après le rendez vous
empêcher de l'année dernière et gelé
comme vous beaucoup regretté avec
plusieurs visages familiers amis de
femmes et d'hommes engagés depuis
plusieurs années à la tête de leur
commune avec leur équipe et que je salue
et une nouvelle génération qui est aussi
arrivé puisque 40% d'entre vous sont
nouvellement élu pendant cette crise
sanitaire
et je veux également avoir une pensée
pour toutes celles et ceux qui ont tué à
gérer cette période de crise de
plusieurs mois
parfois dans l'entre-deux tours pour
certains alors qu'ils savaient qu'ils
allaient arrêter les responsabilités
mais avec le même esprit le même sens du
devoir la même volonté de fer merci
infiniment
[Applaudissements]
alors oui mon premier mot pour toutes et
tous et un mode gratitude et ce ne sont
pas simplement des formules parce que
depuis que nous sommes ensemble dans nos
responsabilités
nous en avons connu des crises
et ça n'a pas
simplement été pour la pandémie et j'ai
toujours vu les maires au coeur au front
de la république les catastrophes
naturelles je me souviens des ouragans
comme des inondations plus récemment aux
antilles des inondations dans l'aude en
ardèche en arrière pays niçois des
épisodes de gel les attentats
terroristes à marseille trèbes paris
strasbourg villejuif romans-sur-isère
conflans sainte honorine nice
les mouvements sociaux
mouvement des gilet jaune aux
revendications ensuite contre certaines
réformes à chaque fois
les mères étaient aux avant-postes
présent avec courage
respect des uns et des autres et avec
capacité à agir au plus vite pour faire
face à la crise mais cette crise du coc
vide évidemment a été toute particulière
et vous a mobilisé d'une manière inédite
et je vous en remercier avec une grande
sincérité
mes prédécesseurs l'ont fait mais vous
pouvez vous applaudir
[Applaudissements]
il a fallu parfois prendre des décisions
rapides difficile surtout au début
lorsque nous découvrions cette épidémie
fallait-il décidé d'un confinement de
fermetures de classes presque du jour au
lendemain vous étiez là aux côtés des
services de l'état pour le faire sall
est il décidé de déployer une politique
de tests inédite dans le pays vous étiez
là aux côtés de l'ensemble de nos
volontaires de nos services de santé nos
pompiers de nos associations pour le
faire fallait-il organisé un plan de
déconfinement et des réouvertures de nos
écoles et mère était là pour le faire
dès le mois d'avril pour préparer le 11
mai fallait il ensuite lancé une
campagne inédite de vaccination vous
étiez là pour ouvrir des centres de
vaccination pour ouvrir de la
vaccination ambulatoire pour aller
auprès des populations les plus fragiles
à chaque étape vous avez été là et je
vous en remercie ce ne sont pas des mots
vous avez innové quand il a fallu à socx
par exemple bâtir un atelier municipal
pour faire des masques pour les enfants
quand aucun commerce dans son lycée vous
étiez là
à hennebont quand les patrouilles d'élus
sont allés pour convaincre les plus
réticents dans les quartiers pour
appliquer des gestes barrières
dans le vercors et aérien partout en
france vous avez pris des initiatives
étaient aux avant-postes de manière très
concrète chaque jour chaque nuit chaque
week-end et donc les résultats qui sont
les nôtres notre capacité à tenir ce fut
la vôtre durant toute cette période
avec vous je veux remercier
l'ensemble de vos équipes municipales
des élus qui sont à vos côtés que je
n'oublie pas et remercier aussi
l'ensemble de vos agents de tous nos
fonctionnaires
qui ont joué un rôle essentiel à vos
côtés et aux côtés des fonctionnaires
évidemment la fonction publique
hospitalière et la fonction publique
d'état ont été aux avant postes de cette
bataille
applaudissons les
alors vous avez été là cet engagement
constant et le gouvernement a été
présent sous l'autorité du premier
ministre jean castex que je tiens ici à
remercier y compris personnellement
ci s'est engagée de la fonction publique
ce maire de prades
après
un autre maire qui le précède dans ses
fonctions a été nommé premier ministre
et bien aussi par sa connaissance son
intimité avec les
collectivités publiques
et les mairies et donc l'engagement du
premier ministre personnel l'engagement
à ses côtés des ministres plusieurs ici
présent que je remercie a été sans
relâche durant toute cette période pour
là aussi transformer les choses bougent
et les administrations être au service
de l'action publique y compris
financièrement dès juillet 2020 500
millions d'euros en garantie de pertes
de recettes 130 millions pour le
remboursement des masques ont été votés
140 millions ont été mobilisés pour les
surcoûts des centres de vaccination un
milliard et demi d'euros
d'investissements ont été débloqués qui
ont abandonné la des cils à cet égard je
m'en remets aux travaux des délégations
collectivités territoriales de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat et je
remercie la présence de la sénatrice gap
l élu député cazeneuve ici présents et
de leur engagement je crois que les
chiffres ont été clairement établie et
l'objectivité clairement tu mises sur
papier
et durant cette période je n'oublie pas
non plus que vous avez été au coeur de
toutes les tensions de la société pour
beaucoup elle préexisté à la crise
elles n'ont fait que croître durant
celle-ci par l'effet de fatigue par les
tensions et elles sont encore présentes
et je veux ici vous dire non seulement
la reconnaissance de la nation mais vous
dire l'engagement de la nation toute
entière
à vos côtés partout il y a le retour de
la violence partout où il ya le retour
de la violence contre celles et ceux qui
détiennent une autorité démocratiques et
légitimes
c'est un bout de république pour dire
et donc nous ne devons rien ni cd rien
j'ai vu parfois certains responsables
politiques
quand ça n'était pas à eux se réjouir
qu'on puisse s'amuser avec des
marionnettes ou guillotine et des
décideurs parce qu'ils ne les aimais pas
ils ne comprenaient pas les malheureux
qu'ils étaient en train de légitimer ce
dont nous sommes tous en train de
victimes d'être victimes les
responsabilités l'incivisme qui ronge
après toute capacité à décider
[Applaudissements]
et donc face au retour à l'augmentation
de la violence nous serons intraitables
comme vous j'ai une pensée émue pour
j'en ai lu michel le maire de signe sa
famille
justice passera
mais j'ai aussi une pensée particulière
pour plusieurs d'entre vous qui encore
ces derniers mois ont été agressés le
maire de mangani à mayotte qui s'est vu
agressé avec son épouse leurs véhicules
brûlés
le maire de valenciennes cher laurent
agressé en juin dernier le soir même de
ces élections
le maire de bron menaces de mort et
entêtant d'entre vous n'ont pas pour en
faire la litanie afin que nous puissions
nous y habituer mais pour dire que la
réaction doit être immédiate et la
sanction décisive c'est d'ailleurs
l'esprit de la récente circulaire du
garde des sceaux permettant de
poursuivre plus rapidement et punir
efficacement ceux qui s'en prennent à
vous et la mobilisation temps de garde
des sceaux que du ministre de
l'intérieur pour qu'à chaque fois la
réaction soit immédiate ce n'est pas de
la solidarité c'est du devoir c'est la
république dont nous parlons
[Applaudissements]
parlant de la crise de ce retour de la
violence je veux comme cela a été fait
m'adresser à vous pour essayer au cid à
ce moment un peu particulier du
quinquennat essayez de voir où nous en
sommes avant ensuite de nous projeter
vers l'avenir
je vous rassure je ne viendrai pas ne
reviendrait pas en détail furent plus de
quatre années et demie d'action publique
il se peut qu'il y ait eu des
malentendus au début
il se peut d'ailleurs qu'il y ait eu des
préjugés
et
j'assume ne pas avoir été maire
vous avez pour toutes celles et ceux qui
m'ont croisé à travers le grand débat et
beaucoup d'autres j'espère pu découvrir
que j'aime et malgré tout beaucoup de
ski et votre action et je pense qu'il ya
d'ailleurs peu de mes prédécesseurs qui
ont passé autant de temps à débattre
avec les maires partout à travers la
france
c'est ainsi je ne suis d'ailleurs pas le
seul président de la vème république à
ne pas avoir été maire j'ai compris
qu'on en aurait beaucoup le général de
gaulle ces derniers temps se peut qu'il
ait eu le même défaut
[Applaudissements]
mais j'ai toujours été à l'écouté des
élus de terrain plusieurs d'entre vous
dont je revois ici les visages amis
shaolin cher karl et j'ai une pensée
émue pour aussi notre ami vanik
berberian en ce jour pouvez l'applaudir
[Applaudissements]
oui au début de la crise et gilet jaune
va venu
avec une délégation de la nrf proposer
ses cahiers de doléances vidéo début du
cahier de doléances sont porte pas
bonheur
dans la vie politique française
mais attention c'était de
proposer une médiation d'essayer
d'offrir la possibilité de contenir la
colère de lui donner un chemin
et il l'a fait avec tous les maires
qu'ils ont suivi avec un entrain une
force de caractère un courage qu'il a eu
jusque dans les dernières heures que je
n'oublierai jamais mais je veux aussi
remercier toutes celles et ceux d'entre
vous à travers tout le territoire qui
m'ont infiniment appris durant cette
période et qui m'ont permis d'affiner à
la fois ma vision du pays de l'action
publique et je crois d'agir plus
utilement au service du pays merci à
vous et merci de m'avoir accueilli à
travers la france entière dans de
nombreux débats et des heures et des
heures de questions réponses merci
au fond si on voulait faire le bilan il
suffirait d'écouter andré laignel
vous avez avec
l'esprit de mesure
la justesse et au fond le sens du détail
qui vous caractérise parfaitement décrit
tout ce que le gouvernement a fait ces
dernières années et je tiens à vous en
remercier
merci chaire andré laignel d'avoir en
font
expliqué que j'ai modestement tâcher de
faire ce que j'avais dit
j'avais dit en effet prenant
l'engagement devant vous je m'en
souviens j'étais alors candidat il y
aura pas de grande réforme
institutionnelle parce que vous êtes
épuisé cela alors il n'y en a pas eu il
n'y en a pas eu comme je m'y étais
engagé à l'exception des changements
portés par les élus eux mêmes avec un
sens imedi justement de la
co-construction par le terrain comme la
création de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace et je remercie la ministre
gourou d'ailleurs pour son engagement
sur ce sujet avec tous les élus
alsaciens ici présents qui l'emporté
mais en effet après tant de loi qui
avait battu institutionnellement les
choses parfois tout bousculer
votre résolution de la cinq ans c'était
pour dire au président précédent arrêté
massat la loi nôtre on n'en peut plus
toutes ces choses là on n'en peut plus
plus de décentralisation malheureux vous
ne vous mettez jamais d'accord nous
l'avons fait
et donc les équipes d'élus les
fonctionnaires territoriaux ont pu
déployer des projets tournés vers le
citoyen plutôt que passer beaucoup de
temps et d'énergie en réorganisation
épuisante bien souvent inefficace
puisque ceux qui portent bien souvent
ces projets sont ceux qui demandent
ensuite de les défaire y reviendrons
la deuxième chose
il faut qu on est collectivement une
forme d'esprit de cohérence si on
appelle au civisme en toute chose elle
avait été au respect il faut aller
jusqu'au bout
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième engagement que j'avais pris
merci pierre andré de l'avoir appelé
c'était de préserver vos moyens
financiers après des années de baisse
après en effet le gel je parle de
chiffres qui sont documentés par tous
après le gel des années 2011 2012 crise
financière oblige le président baroin
s'en souvient il et est aux
responsabilités à l'époque après le gel
il y avait eu la baisse de 10,6
milliards d'euros des années 2012 2017
vient conformément aux engagements pris
la dotation globale de fonctionnement a
été sanctuarisée oui c'est une réalité
[Applaudissements]
alors bien sûr
certaines communes par exemple quand
elles perdaient de la population pu
perdre des dotations certaines communes
quand elle faisait l'objet d'un
réaménagement prévu par la loi notre
retrouvant justement d'autres équilibre
fiscaux et budgétaires on peut perdre
mais les chiffres sont là là où 82 % des
communes rurales avaient perdu sur le
mandat précédent 50 % ont gagné sur
celui ci là où 86 % des villes éligibles
à la dotation de solidarité urbaine les
villes les plus pauvres avaient perdu
65% gagner là au 49 % des communes
d'outre-mer avait perdu
95% ont gagné la vérité des chiffres
c'est toujours mieux de le rappeler
nous avons aussi réalisé un effort
important pour l'investissement dans les
territoires que ce soit en période
ordinaire avec la ddt relais des cils ou
en période extraordinaire avec le plan
de relance est là où à chaque fois qu'il
y avait une crise les collectivités
territoriales dont vos communes étaient
mises à contribution
elles ont été aidées et dotations n'a
pas baissé les engagements ont été tenus
malgré la plus grande récession en
période de paix et dernières décennies
c'est aussi le dernier engagement que
j'avais pris qu'il n'était pas le plus
populaire
c'était la taxe d'habitation
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
que dans un contexte d'inflation élevée
les français en particulier les classes
moyennes peuvent saluer a été compensée
conformément aux engagements à l'euro
près et donc
attaché comme vous
au sens du mandat au fonds au fait qu'
il n'y a pas de confiance il n'y a pas
de loyauté ou alors ce sont des mots si
on ne dit pas ce qu'on va faire et qu'on
n'essaie pas de faire ce qu'on a dit je
peux vous dire que sur toutes ces choses
là ce qui avait été dit a été fait
malgré les circonstances malgré les
événements
tels que je l'avais annoncé également
avant mon élection j'ai toujours
recherché le pragmatisme en partant des
besoins du terrain avec là aussi des
innovations dont je vous remercie
d'avoir salué véritablement le caractère
inédit une fois encore la outre souvent
l'état avait cherché à dicter aux
communes un destin dont elle ne voulait
pas de manière inédite des
contractualisations nouvelles sont
apparues c'est l'esprit même du
programme action coeur de ville qui a
déjà permis à 234 commune de débloquer
des projets qui étaient parfois en
sommeil depuis des années
pas des projets conçus depuis paris non
des rénovations de théâtre des créations
de promenade et réhabilitation de places
qui étaient les projets
que vous portiez parfois depuis des
années et qui ont ainsi pu trouver un
débouché pour les communes de taille
plus modeste avec le plan en petite
ville de demain et des
contractualisations nouvelle spécifique
pour le bassin minier par exemple pour
la sambre avesnois thiérache je serai
demain avec plusieurs ministres
à quimper comme nous l'avons fait
également pour marseille plus récemment
et continuant par ailleurs à déployer
les investissements publics quels que
soient les crises et les difficultés
budgétaires comme en particulier dans le
grand paris où les dernières années ont
été marquées par une agence est conforme
d'ailleurs aux engagements mais
traduites en actes créatrice d'emplois
de solutions de transport et de gares
nouvelles
nous avons aussi durant cette période
avancez vers la différenciation
une action adapté à la singularité de
chaque territoire
d'abord et je souscris complètement ce
que vous avez dit président en essayant
à chaque fois de remettre le maire
davantage au coeur de la décision n'y
sommes pas encore totalement et je
souscris on remarque que vous avez fait
on l'a évoqué tous les deux ensemble
hier mais
il est très clair que ces derniers temps
nous avons remis le maire au coeur de
certaines décisions
les fermetures d'écoles ne sont plus
possibles sans l'accord d'un maire elle
était jusqu'à lors et alors même que
nous avons dédoubler les classes dans
beaucoup de quartiers qui étaient les
plus difficiles nous avons stoppé ce qui
était des coupes sombres dans la
ruralité
quand les maires nous proposer des
solutions et savez construire avec
justement les rectorats et la
collectivité pédagogique de la même
manière je vous ai entendu au sujet des
éoliennes et je remercie nos
parlementaires députés et sénateurs de
chemin qui a été trouvé pour permettre à
partir de février prochain un avis du
maire qui sera pleinement inscrit
justement sur les projets d'éoliennes
dans la la prise de décision et qui
permettra que les documents lui ce fait
soumis qui puisse poser des questions et
donner son ami
[Applaudissements]
la différenciation nous avons aussi
avancé en votant une loi organique qui
permet de déroger aux normes quand la
situation l'exigé par esprit de
pragmatisme là aussi
enfin en assumant de rompre avec des
décennies d'habitude pour faire
confiance au terrain et nous commençons
d'ailleurs collectivement d'innover
grâce à cela c'est par exemple ce que
nous sommes en train de faire à
marseille avec les écoles pour essayer
des méthodes nouvelles grâce à ce cette
capacité à expérimenter sur le terrain
grâce au cadre qui a été permis par la
loi
la fameuse loi 3ds qu'avec la ministre
de la cohésion des territoires vous avez
co construite vous donne également de
nouvelles marges de manoeuvre et je suis
confiant sur le chemin qui sera trouvée
là aussi avec les parlementaires pour
trouver la bonne souplesse et les bons
équilibres conformément à l'esprit de
votre propos pour une bonne souplesse
sur la loi sru et l'adapter aux
contraintes du terrain les travaux qui
ont été conduits le débat je crois
nourrissent une solution pragmatique qui
correspond à notre attachement collectif
à la solidarité et au pragmatisme qui
convient pour que chaque terrain est la
réponse qui lui conviennent ensuite
cette loi va permettre l'accélération de
certaines procédures administratives
nécessaires à la réalisation de vos
projets comme la récupération des biens
sans maîtres en état d'abandon
et le rôle des maires sera conforté dans
la gouvernance des systèmes de santé
aussi grâce à ce texte avec des
premières évolutions
nous avons enfin avec le même
pragmatisme
après les échanges du grand débat
national tout mis en oeuvre pour
faciliter votre vie quotidienne je me
souviens des débats que nous avions à
l'automne 2017 sur les contraintes de la
loi notre et toutes les difficultés tout
n'est pas réglé et je souscris
complètement sur ce que vous avez dit
sur la loi chez mappy
il se trouve d'ailleurs que les mêmes
nappes phréatiques ne suive ni la carte
intercommunale ni la carte communale
elles suivent la carte justement des
bassins versants la plupart du temps ces
dames est donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est
plutôt du pragmatisme de terrain comme
plusieurs territoires ont su le faire
c'est à dire sortir de la bataille de
tranchées entre les communes et les
intercommunalités et au delà des
évolutions déjà prévu trouver des
solutions de territoire qui permettre de
construire mais la noix engagement
proximité a permis des avancées
concrètes que vous attendiez parfois
depuis longtemps
améliorer la prise en charge de vos
frais de déplacements et des frais de
garde de vos enfants réformer la
formation des élus pour permettre
d'envisager la vie d'après mettre en
place une protection fonctionnelle pour
permettre de faire face au risque d'un
monde de plus en plus judiciariser
augmenter les indemnités des maires des
communes les moins peuplées je ne parle
pas de projets à venir je parle de ceux
qui inspirait du grand débat a été mise
en oeuvre dans la loi engagement dé
proximité et simple ce sont des avancées
majeures et sur le sujet de la
responsabilité
les décideurs publics
tâche dire que le travail les derniers
jours des dernières heures du garde des
sceaux du président du sénat et de
l'assemblée nationale va nous permettre
de parachever ce travail pour je crois
construire un cadre qui sera je l'espère
beaucoup plus sécurisant
tout cela c'est à la cavalcade je pense
retracer une partie de ce qui a été fait
mais surtout de l'esprit qui a présidé à
l'action des gouvernements d'edouard
philippe et de jean castex
et je pense que si nous voulons
collectivement avancer il faut que tout
ça puisse être décrits avec ce prix de
mesures honnêteté et pondération vous
avez tous et toutes à faire dans vos
communes à ce type de débat et vous êtes
tous attachés à la même chose
j'en suis un peu le garant ici
alors maintenant pour conclure mon
propos je voulais parler d'avenir et de
ce qui nous reste à faire
collectivement dans les années qui
viennent
n'avons pas fini avec la crise sanitaire
nous le savons nous avons de grands
défis et vous avez soulevé des questions
fondamentales pour la vie démocratique
l'action publique dans notre pays et je
voudrais ici partager avec vous quelques
convictions et au fond ma conviction
principal fait que le travail des maires
des élus de la république
de votre serviteur là où je suis
aujourd'hui
et de tous les fonctionnaires qui sont
au service de notre action c'est de tout
faire pour relever pas simplement les
défis l'urgence
mais réussir à faire nation c'est-à-dire
embrasser notre avenir mais aussi
bâti renforcé la cohésion de notre pays
quelques remarques préliminaires sur ce
point j'ai beaucoup entendu monter ces
dernières années et c'est sans doute le
fruit de l'évolution de la vie politique
et j'ai ma part de responsabilité
fortuitement
un un discours ambiant qui était trop
souvent les élus contre l'état
je pense que ce débat je vous le dis en
toute sincérité est un débat mortifère
parce qu'ils ne correspondent ni à notre
histoire ni à la réalité
constitutionnelle et politique de notre
pays il y a les élus locaux et le
gouvernement
mais l'état est un tout et j'en suis le
garant il peut pas y avoir l'état face
aux élus ça n'est pas vrai
il y à celles et ceux qui sont
responsables devant le parlement
démocratiquement élu c'est le
gouvernement pouvoir exécutif il y à
l'administration qui en possèdent il ya
des élus locaux qui ont leurs
compétences et l'état c'est tout cela
et ne peut pas y avoir ce face à face
sous prétexte qu'il y aurait eu d'autres
émergence politique
et donc l'état je vous le dis avec
beaucoup de solennité c'est vous aussi
c'est vous parce que vous êtes aussi
agents de l'état en même temps que vous
êtes d'élus portant vos projets propres
et parce que si nous serons dans cette
division nous divisons l'action
nous pouvons pas avancer donc il peut y
avoir des désaccords entre des
gouvernements
les administrations qui appliquent leurs
directives des majorités parlementaires
et des élus locaux c'est la vie
démocratique mais ces différences mais
une pop taille avoir une division de
l'état car notre pays a été forgée
fondée par sa langue son histoire et son
état gardons nous gardons nous de toutes
ses forces de divisions surtout dans la
période je le dis avec beaucoup de force
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième chose c'est que
nous sommes toutes et tous dans la
période que nous vivons
soumises à des injonctions
contradictoires par tous les maires que
vous êtes le président que je suis les
gens veulent que ça aille plus vite les
mêmes qui me demande d'aller plus vite
me trouve parfois trop peu autoritaire
on vous fait la même chose sur le
terrain oui monsieur le maire vous
décidez rien fait la concertation on
vous dit que ça prend trop de temps
on est tous attachés à l égalité et les
mêmes quand il ya un maire voisin qui
fait quelque chose qui lui plaît pas a
dit ce que fait le préfet pour le
contrôler mais on voudrait que le préfet
ne l'exercent à points quand c'est sur
soi même bon c'est ça
veillons à une chose tous et toutes en
tant que nous sommes les dépositaires
d'une autorité publique
on fera toujours sifflet où on fera
toujours reprocher tout et son contraire
aux gens qui ne sont pas dans la salle
moi je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
franchise
les fonctionnaires d'état comme les
fonctionnaires des collectivités locales
ils font ce qu'on leur demande ce sont
des gens loyaux et ce sont des gens qui
ont aussi contribué à tenir l'état dans
cette période donc gardons nous de leur
reprocher tout et son contraire
et donc ce qui nous faut collectivement
c'est trouver ensemble les voies d'une
action plus efficace plus légitime plus
rapide
plus simple et je partage totalement ce
que vous avez dit sur ce point dernière
remarque générale pour bâtir l'avenir
c'est au fond cette tension constante
que nous avons entre l'unité et la
diversité
et ça nous n'oublions jamais non plus
quand nous rentrons dans ces débats nous
sommes un pays aux mille terroir
attendent climat tant de vale tant de
différences qui font qu en effet quand
on parle de logement projet vous avez
parfaitement raison y a pas de solution
unique et en même temps nous sommes
construits par cette passion de
l'égalité
par cette passion de l'égalité
et donc nous devons tous ensemble
constamment tenir cette tension et c'est
pour ça que je crois à la
différenciation je ne crois pas en tout
en effet à la remise sur le territoire
de toutes les responsabilités parce que
ce jour-là mais la nouvelle inégalité
que d'autres viendront contre haye nous
en avons encore vu les preuves récentes
alors face à ça je veux de manière très
concrète vous dire en méthode comment
je vois l'avenir avec vous réagissant à
vos propos
d'abord l'autonomie et la donne et la
décentralisation
l'autonomie financière et fiscale
je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit aussi
très honnête entre nous pour savoir de
quoi on parle on a évoqué la taxe
d'habitation vous l'avez rappelé la taxe
d'habitation était un impôt formidable
c'était un impôt dans le premier
contribuable était l'état
c'est ça la réalité c'est un impôt dont
on avait progressivement forte majorité
de la population je crois que c'est le
président une ville comme la vôtre à 3
70% des gens de le payer plus avant la
réforme
c'est l'état qu'il payait aura pouvait
monter et on s'était pas douloureux pour
les gens en général
c'était un impôt sur les classes
moyennes c'était un impôt mauvais pour
les petites villes devenir juste et
c'était un impôt à travers notre
histoire que progressivement
les contribuables en vrai payer de moins
en moins parce que l'état le compenser
si c'est ça l'autonomie fiscale ça
s'appelle pas liberté responsabilité
président c'est pas vrai
et donc oui pour aller vers de
l'assister lité qui clairement soit
fléché à des collectivités mais il faut
avoir un vrai débat de fond comme l'eau
comme longs des pays beaucoup plus
décentralisée je tiens d'abord à son
unique plusieurs pays beaucoup plus
décentralisée que nous non pas de
fiscalité locale ils ont des morceaux de
fiscalité nationale affectés pour
beaucoup ils ont parfois une chambre
spécialisée monsieur le président sur
ces sujets certains de vos homologues
mais qui débat pluriannuel mans de la
fiscalité des dotations là où je vous
rejoins totalement c'est qu'il faut
sanctuariser
ce que deux fêtes nous avons fait durant
quatre ans et demi c'est à dire une
stabilité des dotations mais il faut la
rendre démocratiques transparentes et
regarder si comme d'ailleurs ça a été
fait avec les régions d'autres il ne
faut pas affecté départ d'impôts
nationaux dont la dynamique
correspondait pense à des collectivités
territoriales mais avoir des impôts
qu'ils sont plus payés par les
contribuables pour me dire après que
c'est ce qui constitue le lien c'est un
peu hypocrite et avoir une fiscalité
locale pour certaines tranches dont la
dynamique ne correspond en rien à celles
de leurs dépenses par je pense à nos
départements ça ça ne marche plus
j'ajoutais fort
que l'autonomie fiscale c'est
l'autonomie jusqu'au bout regardez
l'autonomie fiscale des espagnols
la crise de début d année 2010
ça a été autre chose que celle qu'on est
en train de vivre ils n'ont vécu
jusqu'au bout et l'autonomie fiscale ça
veut dire que ça creuse l'inégalité
entre les territoires selon leurs
capacités à la pression
il ya des territoires qui pourront
prélever l'impôt facilement si c'est
bien les contribuables qu'ils payent et
d'autres ils auront beaucoup plus de mal
et l'année la merveilleuse création de
la péréquation si c'est ça qu'on appelle
la simplicité je vous renvoie à nos
débats budgétaires annuels et c'est
exactement ce qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
accru les principes justement de
séparation d'accroissement des
inégalités en renvoyant les communes à
la réalité de leur population leurs
difficultés parfois après de l'emploi
ensuite en compensant par des mécanismes
très complexe on a besoin me semble-t-il
sur ce sujet de pluri annualité de
visibilité de clarté des règles csap
devant bâtir
[Applaudissements]
le deuxième élément ainsi plc la
décentralisation moi je les dix
engagements avaient été pris de ne pas
faire de grands chambardements durant ce
quinquennat engagement a été tenu
mais je voudrais là aussi juste procéder
à une clarification
sémantique au fond politique
nous avons dans notre pays je crois ces
dernières années ces dernières décennies
trop souvent confondue la
décentralisation avec la délégation de
compétence
et ce n'est pas la même chose lorsqu'on
concile le rsa à des départements et
qu'ils n'ont aucune possibilité
de décider des règles de vraiment en
faire la politique mais qui ne sont que
des payeurs aveugles c'est pas de la
décentralisation bilan des courses les
départements les plus pauvres font quoi
ils demandent de recentraliser quand ils
sont en difficulté ce qu'on connaît en
ce moment dans certains territoires
ultramarins en seine-saint-denis c'est
une réalité
parce que ils sont des opérateurs de
l'état y consacrerait injustice et donc
si on veut aller et vous verrez que sur
certains sujets moi qui suis prêt mais
sur la décentralisation il faut que ce
soit un vrai transfert des
responsabilités qui vont avec
clairement est totalement c'est à dire
d'une capacité à décider des règles à en
bouger les normes et en ont décidé les
financements c'est tout ça ensemble mais
tant qu on transférera des compétences
dont les règles continue à être décidée
nationalement ce ne sont pas des
décentralisations
[Applaudissements]
et j'entends celles et ceux qui
appellent à la décentralisation mais
ayant le débat est ce que dans notre
pays on vote pour avoir sans politique
sociale
n'ont
donc c'est pas vrai qu'on a décentralisé
les politiques sociales au département
parce qu'il ya un goût pour l'égalité
parce que personne ne veut que les
règles soient différentes quand il
s'agit du handicap ou de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance entre un département et un
autre est donc ce n'est pas ça la vraie
décentralisation
la décentralisation c'est celle qui
permet de transférer des blocs de
compétences complet la clarté des
financements les responsabilités qui
vont avec avec l'intégralité de ces
règles avançons sur ce chemin avec toute
l'exigence qui convient et pas les
facilités d'hier qui nous ont conduits
aux situations souvent illisibles
déresponsabilisante et avec les
conséquences que nous sommes
collectivement en train de gérer
je crois véritablement
à court terme à une déconcentration et
vous l'avez très bien dit ce souscrit
est ce que vous avez dit président tout
à l'heure comme vous il se peut qu'on
hérite des décisions passées vous
connaissez ça parfois dans vos communes
l'état s'est réorganisé il ya une
décennie en faisant des économies
essentiellement sur les services publics
locaux
les administrations centrales ont peu
réduit leurs effectifs puis la carte
s'est réorganisé son mandat précédent en
faisant des grandes régions qui ont
conduit d'ailleurs les services locaux à
reconcentrer au niveau régional
quand on vit dans une sous préfecture le
résultat est le même que ce soit à la
capitale ou à la capitale de région bien
souvent et donc il est vrai que la
décision était éloigné du terrain par
ses mouvements successifs
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
nous avons recréé ces dernières années
des postes dans les services de
préfecture dans des trésoreries et ce
mouvement doit être amplifiée mais je
tenais c'est à dire il a commencé il a
commencé dans nos trésoreries il a
commencé dans nos forces de sécurité
intérieure il a commencé dans beaucoup
de nos services et je souhaite que nous
allions vers plus de déconcentration en
permettant aussi à nos préfets nous
l'évoquions hier
de disposer tous les leviers pour
apprécier les situations locales et
faire davantage
90% des décisions qui pouvaient l'être
ont été déconcentré les moyens sont en
train d'être remis sur le terrain et à
ça s'ajoute les 2000 maisons france
service en seulement deux ans qui ont
été déployés et qui permettent cette
action locale donc cette marche est en
cours qui doit se poursuivre mais qui
n'est pas un sujet de guerre de
tranchées pour savoir si la compétence
et d'un côté ou de l'autre c'est un
sujet concret qui change plutôt la vie
de nos compatriotes qui est savoir
comment on remet de l'action publique au
contact de nos concitoyens mais je crois
que c'est ça ce à quoi nous sommes
collectivement d'attaché à ce titre les
ministres d'action de la transformation
public a poussé ce mouvement mais aussi
un baromètre de l'action publique sur
les territoires ce qui permet à nos
compatriotes de voir aussi concrètement
ce qu'il fait à la maille de leur
territoire et pas de manière lointaine
ou avec des chiffres qui sont des vrais
simplement des moyennes nationales
vous l'avez compris je crois
profondément à cette action publique
territorialisée par la déconcentration
je crois aussi à l'action publique au
plus proche du terrain par la
contractualisation ce qui a été comme je
commençais à l'évoquer une vraie
révolution de l'action des dernières
années avec un diagnostic partagé avec
la possibilité donner de la visibilité
aux élus que vous êtes les moyens qui
vont avec des résultats et des projets
et pour ce faire je crois que ce que
nous avons commencé à mettre en place et
une méthode utile d'abord avec la
possibilité de bâtir ces contrats sur le
terrain ensuite avec le déploiement
d'une ingénierie adapté c'est tout
l'esprit qui a guidé à la création de l'
agence nationale des territoires dont je
tiens à saluer le travail sous la
présidence de caroline cayeux merci
chers caroline pour ce travail
[Applaudissements]
avec des priorités claires et limiter un
soutien en ingénierie au projet de
terrain et 2700 collectivités soutenu en
un peu plus d'un an d'existence ils
montrent que l' agence nationale des
territoires est d'ores et déjà une
structure qui permet d'accompagner les
projets et d'aller dans ce sens d'une
contractualisation plus forte
ceci ni rack avec comme vous l'avez dit
président plus de simplification
alors la simplification c'est l'une des
choses les plus compliqués à faire
pour partager ce qui est mon quotidien
parce qu'évidemment derrière chaque
norme il ya des conservatismes ya des
gens qui les ont défendus et des gens
qui vous expliquent qu'on peut pas s'en
passer et je pense que vous le vivez
aussi là où vous êtes alors nous avons
déjà réduit le nombre de décrets
autonome fortement les a divisés par dix
on a drastiquement réduit toutes les
circulaires inutile sans créer et je
l'évoqué auprès de vous il ya deux ans
ce qui montre comment on peut encore
aller plus loin
mais il est tout à fait vrai que vos
démarches demeure encore trop complexe
illisible
marqué du sceau de l'incertitude à cause
de ce qu'ils descendent en eau comme
vous l'avait dit et ce qu'il nous faut
faire sur ce sujet est une petite
révolution culturelle elle ne se fera
pas en un jour il n'y a pas de texte
miracle mais
pour partager l'expérience qui est la
mienne je pense qu'il ya quelques
éléments de méthode qu'on doit
collectivement bâtir d'abord ce qu'on
est en train de faire avec cette
déconcentration on a besoin de plus en
plus de fonctionnaires qui aide qui
apporte de solutions sur le terrain et
ils sont preneurs même de ce changement
et c'est un changement d'organisation de
conduite
pour aider accompagner les projets
plutôt que de faire appliquer la norme
est de mettre des tampons
tous nos fonctionnaires soit plutôt cela
c'est plus exaltant ça a plus de sens
pour leur quotidien on doit réussir à
faire cette transformation en effet
notre fonctions publiques d'état et
territoriale et c'est un vrai changement
vrai conduite dans la durée ce ne sont
pas des propos des textes c'est une
vraie transformation qu'il faut faire et
je crois que c'est aussi une question de
respect à leur égard la deuxième chose
c'est que il faut continuer de
simplifier la prise de décision et
l'encadrement des délais au niveau look
et donc ce qu'on a commencé à faire ces
derniers temps en simplifier le en
simplifiant le commandement des services
de l'état au niveau départemental nous
devons le parage fait pour avoir un
décideur unique et pour permettre aux
élus que vous êtes sur des projets
parfois complexes avec les autorisations
multiples d'avoir l'intégration des
scènes des processus d'autorisation au
sein d'une même autorité et
l'encadrement des délais de manière
beaucoup plus drastiques ça a été
commencée sur certains sujets avec élan
ou d'autres ça doit être poursuivie et
systématisée nous en parlions hier
ensemble et je pense que c'est
véritablement cette simplification qui
doit aller à son terme et vous le voyez
bien je pense que ce qu'il nous faut
faire c'est aller vers plus de
déconcentration un plus grand
pragmatisme avec accompagnement des
projets contractualisation et pluri
annualité avec nos mères si on a cette
méthode on peut alors très concrètement
comment on a commencé à le faire avec
l'action coeur de ville mais avec
quelques autres avoir une capacité à
déployer sur le terrain des projets qui
changent la vie de nos compatriotes
nous pouvons tout à fait avoir des
débats politiques sur la
décentralisation
elle doit être systémique elle prendra
du temps mais je pense qu'en parallèle
nous devons continuer à avancer
sur ces sujets
je voulais ensuite en quelque sorte vous
dire aussi que nous avons et nous devons
continuer d'adapter la réponse à la
pluralité des territoires
vous avez commencé à le dire mais je
crois que l'action publique a commencé à
tresser à tram et des réponses à travers
justement ces contrats il faut continuer
de le faire et je pense que pour faire
nation et bâtir l'avenir il faut
continuer de garder l'unité de la nation
et bâtir des réponses différenciées
selon la réalité géographique et
territoriales pour les villes moyennes
cette action coeur de ville je n'y
reviendrai pas mais c'est ce qui a
permis de vraiment de transformer
beaucoup de vos villes et au delà les
près de 250 projets qui ont déjà émergé
ce que nous allons continuer de faire
c'est pour les gares les accès de ville
les quartiers
déployer cette méthode pour aller plus
loin
pour les ruralité qui n'avait jamais
fait l'objet l'objet d'une action
spécifique à ce point
grâce à vanik berberian à michel
fournier au soutien sans faille
de la ministre gouro et secrétaires
d'état giro l'agenda rural a permis de
déployer une véritable action
là aussi j'ai entendu votre résolution
mais je regarde de la même manière les
chiffres et des chiffres sont là sur le
numérique les ministres successifs et je
tiens à saluer l'action aussi du
ministre de normandie se sont battus
deux tiers des locaux sont désormais
raccordés en fibre optique c'était un
quart en 2017 ce qui fait de la france
le pays le plus équipé d'europe grâce à
l'installation de 5000 nouveaux pylônes
le taux de couverture en 4g atteint
aujourd'hui les 98 % des points de plus
qu'en 2017 sont des choses concrètes
sont pas des mots et c'est là pour
beaucoup de communes rurales un
changement de vie profond sur les
transports là où nous avions abandonné
depuis des décennies
les transports du quotidien et les
petites lignes 7 milliards d'euros sur
dix ans d'investissement 7 milliards
d'euros'
j'ai été dans plusieurs de vos communes
où les gens désespérés de voir ces
lignes fermées parce qu'à une réforme de
la sncf est un investissement on rouvre
ses petites lignes en lien avec les
régions et nous pourrons ainsi rénové
plus de 9000 km de lignes ferroviaires
et désenclaver de nombreux territoires
là aussi ce sont des réalités qui change
la ruralité
sur eux toutes nos communes rurales je
serai ici trop long à vouloir tout
évoquée mais de la jeunesse à la vie
associative en passant par l'éducation
nationale et la santé nih riad d'actions
se sont déployés qui permettent de
répondre à cet agenda pour la ville je
vous ai entendu et je souscris
totalement à l'appel de grigny comme au
travail de jean louis borloo les
chiffres sont là
j'ai entendu votre discours mais il a
trois ans d'âge l' agence nationale de
la rénovation urbaine grâce au travail
de la ministre que je salue à
l'engagement d'un d'entre vous olivier
klein qui préside l'anru et que je salue
et que vous pouvez félicité pour son
engagement avec à ses côtés toutes ces
équipes
l'anru maintenant à retrouver 12
milliards d'euros d'engagements il ya
plus de projets qui sont sortis que dans
le projet le poids la première
génération de rénovation urbaine 480
quartiers concernés des moyens
supérieurs dans tous ces endroits au
premier plan c'est ça une réalité veut
dire que on va débattre d'un nouvel
agenda de solution on l'a pris et la
trois ans il a commencé à déployer les
sites et éducative elles ont commencé
les murs sont là les enseignants sont là
il y en aura 200 d'ici l'année prochaine
200 centres de santé les micros folie la
culture que tous les maires qui les
vivent les portes et les explique je
pense qu'il ya un problème d'information
compte tenu de la résolution que vous
avez vu tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
et donc vous le voyez oui nos quartiers
ont droit à l'investissement de la
république ils n'ont eu avant la crise
pendant la crise ils l'auront après la
génération de rénovation urbaine est
encore plus forte que la première parce
qu'elle s'est inspirée des travaux de
jean louis borloo et parce qu'elle s'est
inspirée de l'action de notre maire de
quartier qui partout se bat et ont
décidé d'aller plus loin et ça
continuera cher karl avec le sport pour
bientôt
ces géographies elles sont multiples et
il vous appartient de réunir en effet
l'ensemble de ses élus de communes de
montagne qui ont fait l'objet d'un plan
inédit pendant la crise et nos élus le
savent de communes littorales j'étais à
leurs côtés encore il y a quelques jours
dans l'hérault de nos communes
forestières et je veux ici vous rassurer
président le premier ministre avec les
ministres compétents à puurai assurer
les quatorze mille communes forestières
il n'y aura pas de prélèvements
supplémentaires il y a au contraire des
défis l'état dans les prendre en charge
à travers la politique qu'il a lancée et
ce point sera réglé
s'agissant de l'outre-mer vous l'avez
évoqué et nos élus d'outre-mer sont
porteurs de toutes ces ces défis qu'il
s'agisse des défis de l'eau de
l'éducation de la santé de la sécurité
et nous aurons l'occasion en particulier
pour mayotte de porter ces difficultés
et la réponse à celle ci à travers un
texte de loi haddock et nous avons lancé
en particulier fin 2020 un dispositif
le dispositif du contrat de redressement
outre-mer qui permet aujourd'hui à sept
communes volontaires de bénéficier d'un
accompagnement inédit pour se redresser
financièrement et je veux saluer les
maires qui se sont engagés dans cette
procédure et l'investissement aussi qui
a été le nôtre pour eux pour ce faire et
je veux en l'évoquant ici aussi avoir
une pensée particulière pour
les 33 maires de nouvelle calédonie le
12 décembre matin dans moins d'un mois
désormais les bureaux de vote seront
ouverts pour que les calédoniennes et
les calédoniens qui le souhaitent
puissent décider de construire leur
amour et de statuts un statut plus de
statut en organisation politique la
commune a traversé toutes les évolutions
institutionnelles de l'histoire
calédonienne
et au lendemain de la dernière
consultation d'autodétermination l'état
dont c'est le rôle et la responsabilité
historique
reprendre à l'initiative du dialogue
pour la période de transition de 18 mois
qui s'ouvrira alors
et je souhaite que les mères calédonien
ils soient étroitement associés
mais je veux ici les remercier car
durant ce mandat nous avons eu à tenir
les trois référendum qui était prévu par
les accords historiques et les maires
ont été au rendez vous avec beaucoup de
courage de détermination
l'esprit civique mercier
[Applaudissements]
et donc pour bâtir au delà de sa
diversité de territoires grâce à ces
quelques principes que j'évoquais
auxquelles je crois à l'avenir nous
devons nous attaquer en effet à quelques
priorités de la nation que vous avez
retracer l'un et l'autre évidemment le
sanitaire qui va continuer je ne serais
pas ici l'on
l'actualité si je puis dire nous occupe
qu'ils aient tous mais nous allons
continuer à nous battre dans les
prochains mois avec la même constance la
même détermination ensuite le
redressement économique
le plan france relance a permis de
beaucoup faire et de beaucoup avancé de
territorialiser beaucoup de projets il
en sera de même pour france 2030 on
continuera avec le même traumatisme a
avancé adapter les choses à simplifier
en effet pour que les appels à projets
je vous ai entendu puisse correspondre
aux réalités du terrain vous avez
parfaitement raison il faut constamment
s'améliorer pour que les choses prennent
en compte la réalité et la souplesse
nécessaires
d'ores et déjà nous avons collectivement
fait quelque chose d'inédit dans notre
histoire
près des trois quarts de nos pme ont été
touchés par les aides ça s'est fait
parce que les mères ont été impliqués
parce que malgré tout on avait quand
même des instruments qui devait être
relativement simple pour y arriver plus
simple qu'on ne le dit parfois et donc
il faut continuer d'être très simple
très réactif d'aller au plus près du
terrain avec pragmatisme mais vous serez
des acteurs de cette relance économique
et de la construction de france 2030 qui
est indispensable pour bâtir notre
avenir
ensuite c'est évidemment au delà de
l'épidémie la santé vous l'avez
parfaitement dit et beaucoup d'entre
vous se se battent au quotidien pour
lutter contre les déserts médicaux les
difficultés de l'hôpital je vous ai
entendu président tout à l'heure mais
moi je suis ouvert à toutes les
évolutions institutionnelles il est
clair que nous devons faire évoluer
l'organisation de notre système de santé
dès le projet
présenté en 2018 avant la crise nous
avons veillé à décloisonner la ville et
l'hôpital a levé le numerus clausus à
revenir sur des erreurs passées qui
avait progressivement construit les
difficultés que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et nous avons d'ailleurs ces
dernières années beaucoup amélioré les
choses par la suppression du numerus
clausus du recours à la télé mais steen
le déploiement des assistants médicaux
des communautés de soins etc etc mais
tout ça ne va pas assez vite d'abord
parce que vos difficultés au quotidien
demeure parce qu'on met dix ans a formé
des nouveaux médecins et parce que la
réalité de certains territoires est déjà
là et donc nous devons aujourd'hui aller
beaucoup plus loin et plus fort sur le
décloisonnement entre la ville et
l'hôpital oui nous devons
débureaucratiser l'hôpital et la gestion
des soins pour remettre les élus mais
aussi des soignants être avant tout au
coeur de cette gouvernance et il nous
faut absolument construire des solutions
de santé publique à l'échelle des
territoires et le faire en s'appuyant
aussi sur ce que sur les trésors
d'innovation que beaucoup d'entre vous
ont su déployer qui consiste à ouvrir
les hôpitaux cher président la
fédération de ce mr ouvrir les hôpitaux
à des professionnels de santé et donc à
des spécialistes qui ne viennent pas
s'installer sauf si on leur permet
urologue aux autres de venir s'installer
à l'hôpital pour partie et de pour
partie en ville on arrive à attirer des
médecins on ne sait si on offre des
perspectives de travail à leur conjoint
et leurs conjointes
si on arrive à maintenir l'école c'est
une solution d'ensemble qu'on tricote si
je puis dire avec action coeur de ville
avec tout ce qui est mis en place pour
remettre de la vie dans nos territoires
là où il y avait eu de la déprise
démographique c'est ça le débat et le
défi qui est le nôtre on le sait bien
donc la réponse elle n'est pas que ça
n'y perd lé d'ensemble mais on va
continuer à se battre et sur ce sujet
d'abord nous ne céderons jamais aux
situations inacceptables et plusieurs
d'entre vous les ondes dénoncé le maire
de barneville-carteret dans la manche en
particulier ces derniers temps a été
vocale à juste titre mais nous
continuerons de nous battre pour
accélérer ce qui a été commencé et pour
tirer toutes les leçons de la crise ou
quand nous avons résisté c'est que nous
avons su qu'elle fait des murs levée des
barrières qu'il y avait entre les
secteurs
l'autre défi évidemment que nous devons
embrasser ensemble c'est la sécurité
pour bâtir l'avenir et cette cohésion
face à ce retour de la violence là aussi
il y a eu des actions l'état c'est son
rôle régalien vous l'avez dit n'a pas
simplement mener des débats ou lancer
des grandes discussions il a agi dix
mille policiers et gendarmes qui sont en
train de finir de se déployer sur le
terrain beaucoup d'entre vous voulez
voir d'ailleurs 10000 ça n'est pas rien
alors parfois ça répare ce qui avait été
fait avant
je suis désolé mais pour garantir la
tranquillité publique c'est une chose
l'état ne se désengage pas au contraire
il se réengagent avec force et vous vous
réengager avec force à ses côtés je
salue le travail du ministre de
l'intérieur et du garde des sceaux
ministre aura apporté une loi de
sécurité globale
et d'apporter une loi de sécurité
globale il leur a apporté une loi de
programmation de sécurité intérieure
mais d'ores et déjà avec la loi qui a
été promulguée grâce d'ailleurs à
l'expérimentation de plusieurs d'entre
vous
se sont davantage de marge de manoeuvre
qui sont donnés aux polices municipales
c'est un continuum de sécurité dans le
cadre de la contractualisation entre
toutes les forces de sécurité intérieure
et donc on a renforcé le lien entre les
communes leur police et la police
nationale ou la gendarmerie on va
continuer ce travail aller beaucoup plus
loin et la loi de programmation qui se
préparent pour le début d'année
prochaine va permettre d'aller encore
plus loin sur ce sujet à travers des
réorganisations et des avancées de la
même manière je sais que vous avez pu
travailler avec le garde des sceaux pour
avancer sur le dialogue entre les
magistrats et les maires que vous et
nous allons poursuivre ce qui a été
commencé pour justement par achever ce
travail et continuer d'améliorer la
rapidité de la réponse en particulier la
réponse pénale mais aussi la réponse sur
les petites incivilités et là aussi
d'ores et déjà des moyens étaient
déployés sur le terrain continueront de
l'être et des réformes ont été passées
et continueront d'être complété
vous avez évoqué aussi rapidement parler
d'avenir c'est parler de l'école et ce
défi de l'école c'est évidemment le
coeur de la promesse républicaine vous
avez été les partenaires de plusieurs
réformes durant les dernières années
d'abord nous avons ensemble corriger je
crois des choses qui avait bousculé les
maires sur les rythmes nous avons
ensuite construit des réponses
différenciées là où sur le terrain il y
avait des besoins avec les dédoublements
y compris en allant plus loin dans
certains contrats territoriaux et nous
devons maintenant passer une étape
supplémentaire et de la même manière je
suis convaincu pour ma part que l'école
de la confiance et l'école de demain se
construire en renforçant ce partenariat
entre justement l'éducation nationale et
les maires et entre le temps scolaire et
périscolaire dans notre capacité à bâtir
ce continuum dans la prise en charge des
enfants en particulier les plus fragiles
comme nous sommes en train de le faire à
marseille et dans plusieurs autres
territoires comme nous le faisons aussi
à travers ce qui a été pensé pour les
sites et éducative et pour les quartiers
les plus en difficulté dans la
république et donc co construire ces
politiques éducatives avec vous
continuer à innover à avancer est un
défi absolu
vous m'avez ans 1 sollicité c'est le
président sur le logement
et le logement comme la transition
écologique car les deux combats sont
jumeaux font partie des défis du pays à
la fois parce que nous devons en faire
évoluer les règles mais nous devons
aussi permettre à nos compatriotes de
vivre bien et que nous sommes tous
soumis là aussi à des changements de
comportement de pratique que cette crise
a accéléré les gens veulent améliorer
leur qualité de vie ils veulent parfois
habités à un autre endroit que celui où
il travaille de plus en plus il veut
répartir leur temps différemment le
télétravail a fait naître cela plusieurs
d'entre vous sont soumis à une pression
qui est liée aussi aux résidences
secondaires qui sont multipliés et ses
réorganisations de vie viennent
bousculer des territoires en même temps
que nous avons des territoires qui
perdent de la population d'autres qui
sont sous forte sion démographique une
diversité qui fait qu'il est très
difficile d'avoir une politique unifiée
en tout cas uniforme
en matière de logement ces dernières
années nous avons réussi ensemble des
combats on les a réussies grâce à
plusieurs partenaires
les maires que vous êtes et tous ceux
qui accompagnent l'action publique et je
veux vraiment ici remercier la caisse
des dépôts et consignations la banque
des territoires action logement la
banque postale ce sont des acteurs et
des partenaires de beaucoup d action que
j'ai évoqué le coeur de ville à d'autres
mais en matière de logement et grands
projets ils sont déterminants et ils
sont des opérateurs du quotidien et de
vos projets néanmoins
si nous avons réussi à enclencher la
rénovation des logements de manière
historique
est véritablement un passé un cap depuis
18 mois a enclenché la modernisation et
la transformation l'adaptation au
vieillissement de certains logements si
nous avons répondu en terme
d'hébergement d'urgence nous avons un
problème de construction qui demeure le
cycle électoral n'a pas été favorable et
la pandémie non plus soyons lucides on
sait comment tout cela marche mais on
voit bien que malgré les évolutions de
la loi est lent
tout ça n'a pas été suffisamment
simplifiée
aujourd'hui le nombre de permis de
construire délivrés
recommencent à augmenter mais après un
niveau historiquement bas et donc il
nous faut là aussi avoir des réponses
des réponses de court terme pour
inverser cette tendance françois
rebsamen a fait récemment des
propositions très pertinente et il
appartiendra à l'exécutif et au
parlement de l'accompagner mais on doit
là aussi essayer de voir comment
articuler toutes nos contraintes et à
côté de ça vous l'avez évoqué il y à cet
objectif de zéro artificialisation net
là dessus je veux être clair
cet objectif n'est pas de stopper toute
construction ou d'arrêter des projets
c'est au contraire je dirais plutôt de
ralentir le rythme qu'il conduisait a
supprimé l'équivalent d'un département
de terres agricoles et espaces naturels
tous les dix ans
c'est un là
où nous urbanisation où nous
artificielle ision quatre fois
vite trop vite de diminuer par deux cet
effort alors il faut un l'adapter aux
réalités des territoires peut-être nixon
a été fait et 2 je vous ai entendu
laissé le temps pour que ce soit bien
fait on a toujours eu cet esprit de
pragmatisme nous louerons il est évident
qu'on mettra jamais un maire devant un
couperet mais la clé de tout ça c'est
que les maires et la possibilité de
programmer sur plusieurs années cette
stratégie est la possibilité d'avoir les
instruments pour le faire mais tout ça
correspond au projet vous êtes en train
de faire vous toutes et tous vous avez
des communes dont les accès ont été
dégradées par des zones commerciales
qu'il correspond plus au goût du jour
par des zones industrielles qu'ils
correspondent plus aux goûts de nos
compatriotes par des espaces qui sont
devenus souvent les parts des centres
villes qui ont été abandonnées tout ce
qu'on est en train de faire avec actions
de coeur de ville petite ville de demain
avec le plan friche où on a investi
massivement et nous allons continuer à
investir c'est vous donner les moyens de
continuer à avoir des projets de
logement des projets pour vos
entreprises mais en reconvertissant
justement mes usages et pas en allant
conquérir de nouvelles terres agricoles
ou autres c'est exactement ce que vous
voulez faire simplement là où je vous
rejoins il faut que tout se retrouve sa
cohérence il faut bien mieux qu'on est
aux quelque sorte une direction
nationale une contractualisation locales
et des moyens clairs qui serait donnée
aux collectivités pour porter ces
projets c'est dans ce sens qu'on ira
vous avez ici mon sens de mon engagement
mais je peux vous dire qu'on peut le
faire et que nous pouvons à la fois
grâce au fond ce riche doté de 650
millions d'euros et pérenniser pour les
années à venir et à tout cela faire plus
de logements mieux de logements et
réussir à tenir nos objectifs collectifs
c'est possible et nous allons le faire
[Applaudissements]
mais sur ces deux sujets je veux vous
dire ma conviction profonde
je pense qu'au niveau national
nous devons fixer des stratégies
l'objectif de logements évidemment de
logement social et d'hébergement
d'urgence que sur le plan de la
transition climatique nous devons nous
donner des objectifs nous sommes
d'ailleurs sur le plan international
débiteur et c'est l'état qui se fait
condamner même quand des collectivités
parfois ne contribue pas c'est une
réalité juridique que nous avons encore
vu récemment
mais qu'ensuite ça n'est pas la loi qui
doit tout prévoir
et que sur des sujets comme le logement
et la transition écologique
il faut aller vers une décentralisation
bien plus massive parce que c'est
cohérent avec la réalité de nos
territoires et de nos bassins de vie et
sur ces deux sujets je pense que les
objectifs les grands objectifs doivent
rester nationaux mais que la traduction
des politiques beaucoup plus qu'on ne le
fait aujourd'hui doit revenir à
l'échelle de la commune à l'échelle de
la métropole à l'échelle du territoire
de vie de nos compatriotes
voilà les quelques convictions
mesdames et messieurs les maires chers
amis que je voulais partager avec vous
je n'ai pas
tout couvert mais j'ai essayé de
répondre à beaucoup des sollicitations
qui m'avait défaite en essayant de dire
de rendre justice aux gouvernements
successifs et en essayant de vous dire
ma conviction profonde là aussi avec la
même franchise et la même honnêteté
j'ai tâché là où j'étais de faire ce que
j'avais dit
et je crois que c'est le cas
j'ai tâché de m'adapter comme vous
d'ailleurs à toutes les crises que nous
avons subies et nous avons tenu et je
vous remercie de cela
mais n'oublions jamais que l'ensemble de
nos compatriotes
toujours nous regardent et qu'au fond
ils attendent de nous d'être
à la hauteur de nos fonctions ils
attendent de nous
de porter le sens cet esprit civique qui
nous anime toutes et tous et je sais ce
qui vous tient au quotidien et c'est ce
que nous allons continuer de faire
quelles que soient les vents mauvais
quelles que soient les esprits de
division de discorde qui parfois rennes
parce que ce que nous avons
collectivement accompli avec toutes
celles et ceux qui oeuvrent à nos côtés
c'est un travail de résistance inédit à
une crise séculaire mais c'est aussi la
capacité à bâtir notre avenir
est à construire l'espérance qui va nous
permettre de regarder devant
et avec cela
internations véritablement
il ya dans le beau mot de mer
l'anagramme de vrd mais
parce qu'au delà de tout ce que vous
faites il ya un engagement qui est de
coeur et d'âme mais quelque chose qui ne
se réduit pas aux politiques publiques
parfois au sujet
un peu difficile ou techniques que nous
avons pu aborder aujourd'hui mais
c'était bien normal et légitime
oui il ya toujours cette part de sens
d'affection
d'attachement quelle votre à votre
fonction à votre coming à votre
territoire qui est le nôtre à notre
nation
ne laissait ne laissons rien rien
entamé cet attachement
ne laissons rien entamé ce qui est au
fond
notre vocation première
est celle qui nous tient chaque jour
toujours ré expliquer à nos compatriotes
les raisons que nous avons de vivre
ensemble
et ces raisons là sont plus forte que
tout
elle nous tiennent elles sont faites de
projets des projets que vous portez deux
quotidiens d' enthousiasme et de sens
alors regardons toujours à devant
croyons en nous ans que nous sommes en
la france merci pour votre action vivent
les communes vivent les maires de france
vive la république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
anwar
je
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
tout change